Hello.
So a couple of you who are out there,
maybe you can just send me a quick text
and tell me if this is working.
Yes.
Excellent.
Can you hear me
Mad Matt?
I work at Mars in Toronto.
Can you share your thoughts and why it
hasn't worked?
Wow,
that's a complicated question.
Let's get to that a little bit later.
You guys can hear me.
Excellent.
Let's go.
So this is what I'm going to do.
I want to talk to you first about
Patriarchy and then I'm going to take
some questions that people have said.
I've got this new thing called a pigeon
hole and that's enabled people to vote
up questions and then I'm also going to
take some of the questions that are on,
um,
you know,
that are streaming in so,
so hopefully that'll all work.
See if I'm in focus.
Not too bad.
All right,
there we go.
Consider the overwhelming success of the
Patriot and counted the money raised by
rebel.
What will you be doing with their
contributions?
Well that's great.
All right,
so I've got a couple of things to say
about that.
So the first one is,
you know,
I would say a number of people have been
attempt and not an overwhelming number,
but a number of people have been
attempting to take me to task for the
fact that my patriotic support has been,
let's call it overwhelmingly successful.
And,
and so I'll tell you how I formulate my
response to that.
The first is I'm generating almost all
of my content and making it completely
publicly accessible so it's free,
right?
And,
and so that way I'm bringing I think,
awareness of psychological issues to a
very large number of people.
And so far at the moment,
my view count on Youtube is up to 13
million and I've did,
did a little bit of calculations last
week to try to figure out what the total
view count was,
um,
for,
for the cuts of my lectures that have
been appearing on youtube and then the
political material as well.
And I think it's upward of 50 million.
And so I'm making psychological and
political content available to 50
million people.
And so,
you know,
that
seems like a reasonable thing to do.
Now,
people who don't agree with what I'm
saying might differ,
but I think that could be separated from
the educational content as well.
So,
and then with regards to the Patriot on
subscribers,
every single person who's doing that is
doing it entirely voluntarily.
And I also set up that Patriot on
account long before any of this
political material emerged.
So my sense with the patron viewers,
and you guys can clue me in if I'm wrong
about this,
is that there's two things happening is
one is it enables people who are not
very happy about the current political
situation in the west to,
to,
to uh,
contribute to something that might be at
least to some degree attempting to stem
the tide of such things as toxic
political correctness.
And second that it enables people to
support my endeavors,
to bring general education to a wider
audience.
And that seems like a good deal for
everyone.
And you know,
you might say,
well,
it's a particularly good deal for me and
I'm certainly not complaining about
what's happening,
but I would also point out that,
um,
it hasn't exactly been a straight
forward thing.
And so,
um,
so I guess if anyone else wants to try
it,
they're more than welcome to.
Now having said that,
um,
I would also say that the real issue
here,
and I think this is the fact that this
isn't self evident is also a commentary
on the toxicity of our culture at the
moment,
is that it actually isn't the issue.
The issue isn't really how much money
you have.
I think that that's a resentful and at
relatively vicious way of judging
someone else.
I think the issue is what you do with
the money when you have it.
And you know,
um,
I'm not a particularly hedonistic person
and I'm not 25 years old,
you know,
I'm 55 years old and I'm going to be a
grandfather in a couple of months,
you know,
thank God for that.
Um,
and what I want to do with that money is
to do the best things I can possibly
think of to do with it.
And one of the things I'm thinking
about,
I started this biblical series and a lot
of that's help,
thankful thanks to you guys on Patrion
because that enabled me to generate the
capital that was necessary to rent the
theater because for 12 lectures,
that was a $60,000 investment about
that,
something like that.
And then another $8,000 for the,
for the camera work.
And that had to be basically,
uh,
dealt with upfront.
So it was a reasonable financial risks.
Now I've been s crazily fortunate in
that the theater tickets have also sold
out.
So it looks like the biblical series
will pay for itself with some extra
leftover.
And so,
you know,
I'm pretty happy about that because that
gives me some more working capital.
And then you might say,
well,
what am I going to do with the capital?
Well,
I'm going to continue doing the sorts of
things that I'm already doing.
I want to do a series on the hundred
greatest books of the western Canon,
for example.
I want to move genuine humanities
education out of the universities where
it isn't being taught anyways.
As far as I can tell online where people
can access it freely.
I'm talking to a wide variety of people
right now about trying to do that in a
more formal sense so that the
possibility for widespread university
education can be universally accessible.
And one of the things we're trying to
crack is the problem of how to teach
people to write.
Cause that's a real troublesome thing.
And by the way,
you know,
you guys,
if you go onto my website,
Jordan peterson.com and you go into
courses
and you go into psychology for 30 if you
look carefully there,
you'll see that there's an essay rubric
that teeth that tells people how to
write.
And actually that's become quite
popular.
And so if you're interested in how to
learn to write,
I've written something about that
already and we're going to make a piece
of software that's going to help people
learn to write.
And so I've got plans for how to make
writing education broadly accessible to
people.
So I would like to make humanities
education of the highest order,
broadly accessible to people.
And I also want to teach them how to
write.
And I'm going to try to crack the online
university accreditation problem.
And so part of the money that,
or a substantial proportion of the money
that is being donated to me,
let's say,
or is being offered to me by my monthly
supporters.
So that's all of you people is going to
be going to projects exactly like that.
And the reason for that is,
is that what the hell else would I do
with the money?
You know,
I mean,
to me money is a tool.
It's not,
it's not the means whereby you develop a
luxurious lifestyle and spend your time
burning yourself,
have to death in the sun,
in the Caribbean,
snorting cocaine and chasing hookers.
You know,
it's just,
that's just not in the cards for me.
Um,
and uh,
and so I want to devote it towards the
sorts of things that I've already been
pursuing except on a broader scale.
And so you know,
and I think of people like Elon Musk to,
not that I'm comparing myself to Elon
Musk,
but I mean he has plenty of money and I
mean you really,
somebody's got to have the damn money.
It might as well be people who have the
kind of vision that people like he does
have because maybe they'll do something
good for the world.
I mean I hope his gigafactories produce
batteries like mad so that we can start
to make alternative energy sources
economically viable and maybe reduce our
dependence on oil and maybe get
ourselves out from underneath the thumb
of the Saudi Arabs.
That would be a good thing.
So the monetary issue,
it's,
it's quite interesting.
It's like it is not the,
you have the money,
it's what you do with it.
And so anyways,
those are some of my plants and that
isn't all of them because I'm going to
come up with a bunch more plans and I'm
going to try to implement them as
rapidly as I possibly can.
I've put my clinical practice on hiatus
for the next three months so that I have
a chance to think,
and I've requested that the university
advanced my sabbatical by one year.
So I should have about a year to think
about what I should be doing with
youtube and how I can be promoting broad
scale public education of the highest
quality.
And that's a really fun problem to
solve.
And the fact that I'm being supported by
all of you people on Patrion makes the
probability that avail to that all be
able to devote my time to that much
higher.
So,
so that's what I'm going to do with it.
I'm going to do the best things I can
possibly think of to do with it.
And uh,
hopefully that'll work.
And so far it seems to be going well.
So,
um,
yeah,
I mean I've been taken aback back quite
a bit by the,
I mean,
it's not surprising that,
you know,
the people who've been trying to take me
down,
let's say are squawking and bitching
because I happened to be generating a
fairly reasonable income from this,
although I don't think about it as an
income,
as I already said,
I think about it as a,
as a toolkit for pursuing more
interesting things.
It's like if that's the best they can do
with regards to continuing to tarnish my
name,
well then let them,
let them go right ahead about that.
And uh,
I think the proof is in the outcome and
the biblical series and that's a direct
consequence of the Patriot and support
that seems to be going like mad.
I think,
you know,
about 500,000 people have watched the
videos so far with another,
who knows,
tens of thousands of people listening to
the podcasts.
And that's just a bloody miracle that,
that many people would be interested in
what I consider the fundamental
foundation for any true humanities
education.
So great.
We'll build from there.
And so that's,
that's what I'm going to do with the
money.
So,
and if people don't like that,
then they don't have to donate or they
don't have to subscribe.
It's hardly like it's mandatory.
So anyways,
I'll stop with that and I'll get to
another question or a question.
Another question.
Um,
here's one that got 264 votes so far,
is the belief in something more than
experienced reality unreasonable.
Okay.
So I want to address that question
technically to begin to begin with
because one of the things that you want
to do when someone asks you a question
is that you want to take a look at the
question because the question boxes you
in in a certain way.
And if you're going to answer the
question you make,
you have to make sure that you've
properly processed the structure of the
question.
So let's look at this one.
Is the belief in something more than
experienced reality unreasonable.
And so then I'm going to go socratic on
this and say,
well,
it depends on what you mean by belief
experienced reality,
something more and unreasonable and and
see the problem is you can't really
answer a question like that unless you
delve into the definitions.
So let's say,
well,
what do you mean by experienced reality?
Do you mean that which is directly
grippable by the senses?
While then I would say,
well do you believe in numbers?
Because numbers aren't directly
experienceable,
but obviously they're real.
If you define reality as the use of
concepts that give you grip and power in
the world.
And I think because I'm a pragmatist in,
I mean part of the way that I define
something as real is whether or not it
has functional operative status in the
world.
And so the belief in something more than
experienced reality is obviously clearly
reasonable.
If you regard abstractions as something
more than experienced reality.
And that brings up another issue.
And the issue is whether or not
instructions or even more real than
experienced reality.
And I would say often they are because
otherwise abstraction wouldn't work.
So it's definitely not unreasonable.
And then you,
do you mean merely subjectively
experienced reality or do you mean the
kind of reality that can be experienced
by multiple people at the same time?
Because that's also different that the
ladder is more in the domain of
scientific inquiry.
And I think the problem with belief in
subjectively experienced reality is not
so much that what you experience
subjectively isn't real is that you can
get the categories wrong.
You know,
dreams are real,
but they're not the same kind of real as
things in the outside world that other
people can experience.
And to conflate the two or to failure
fail to distinguish between them as a
form of insanity.
But that doesn't mean that both of them
aren't real.
So,
um,
so the simple answer to the question is
the belief is the belief in something
more than experienced reality.
Unreasonable is no,
but it depends on,
it depends on your specific definitions
of all those terms and those sorts of
things really matter.
Okay.
Bet.
Bob Asbury says,
I'm a 58 year old American redneck who
never went to college a day in his life.
Okay.
But I feel like I'm getting a world
class education every day.
Thank you,
Dr. Peterson.
You are very cool.
Well thank you.
I don't know how cool I am exactly,
but I am.
I tell you,
man,
and this is the dead truth.
I am absolutely thrilled that I have the
opportunity to provide educational
resources to people all over the world.
It's a dream,
you know,
really,
I mean,
it's an absolute privilege.
So when I get letters from people like
you very,
very frequently from all over the world,
you know,
one the fact that now we have the
technology to allow people in principle
to have a world class university
education is mind boggling.
And here's something I think is
absolutely comical.
And I'd been pursuing this with a group
of people that I've been discussing.
Um,
I've been having intense discussions
with some in Silicon Valley and some in
Montreal,
in some,
in Toronto.
You know,
the f here's the university situation in
many ways.
Number one,
they're putting students in debt in a
tremendous way in the United States over
because of overpriced education.
They don't let the students,
um,
declared bankruptcy because of the
doubt.
Okay.
And so it's basically indentured
servitude.
And so then students come out of
university and death it heavily at the
time of their life when they should be
relatively free of financial burdens so
that they can be creative and
entrepreneurial because you're going to
do that when you're young,
generally speaking,
then the universities have become
administratively top heavy and,
and stultified because of that,
then they've abandoned their commitment
to the humanities,
right?
Then they're not utilizing modern
technology to extend the reach as
broadly as they possibly could.
Then they've,
they've,
uh,
in some sense abandoned their
responsibility to do a crediting
properly and devalued the value of the
degree because they treat their students
like consumers and,
and,
and inflate the grade currency.
So to me,
that's a perfect storm of error.
And so I see an opportunity emerging
right now where the intellectual
property that's related to the true
humanities and that would be at least in
part,
the western Cultural Canon could just be
taken out of the universities grip and
provided to people in high quality form
online.
And if I can crack,
how to teach people to write and then
also to figure out the accreditation
problem,
which I don't think is,
uh,
it's not an overwhelmingly complex
problem.
It's complex,
but not overwhelmingly then there's no
reason that the university can't moved
to Kent Move Online.
And I would say the true university
exists where people are pursuing
education because they bloody well want
to get educated because they know that
being sharp and articulate and
historically informed and
philosophically wise and all of that
makes their lives better,
makes them better citizens,
makes them more responsible.
And so I want to follow the university
where it goes and as far as I'm
concerned,
the universities where people want to
listen to wisdom and I'm going to try to
dispense wisdom to the degree that I'm
fortunate enough to have access to it.
So,
um,
anyways,
Bob,
like I'm thrilled that I can be of
service to you and um,
it's a real privilege and so,
and we're going to do more of that.
So.
All right.
So another question.
Am I feeling all right?
How is my health?
Well that's a good question.
Um,
I've had,
I've had a history of depression as some
of you may know it,
it's a plague in my family.
It goes back many generations and also
has afflicted one of my children quite
badly.
But we are figuring this out and I'm
actually feeling pretty good right now
for the first time in about seven or
eight months.
I'm really looking forward to the future
again and I'm getting my energy back.
And when I have energy,
I have a lot of energy.
And uh,
so,
and because I put my clinical practice
on hiatus and because I've applied for a
sabbatical and I'm going to have some
time and because of this massive
construction project that I've been
engaged in in my house,
cause I put a,
basically a native American longhouse on
the ceiling of my house,
believe it or not,
maybe one day.
I'll walk you through that if you'd be
interested.
Um,
I'm going to have a lot of time and I'm
finishing a book and it's due on June
5th.
It's called 12 rules for life and
antidote for chaos.
And that's just about done.
And it'll be out January 9th,
I think,
2018 then,
uh,
you know,
that's going to clear up an awful lot of
time for me.
And so my health is good.
I've lost about 50 pounds because I've
stopped eating carbohydrates almost
completely.
And so that's bloody unbelievable.
I'm back down to the weight I was when I
was 30 and uh,
I think that I'm going to get on top of
my health problems.
And my daughter who's had
extraordinarily serious health problems,
including two hip,
like a hip replacement when she was 16
and an ankle replacement.
She,
when she was also 16,
she walked around on two broken legs for
a whole year in excruciating agony.
Like she's figured a lot of this out and
she's offer auntie or her immune
suppressant medication and all sorts of
other things.
So it's a painstaking process.
And I've been eating nothing,
literally nothing but beef,
chicken and salad for a whole month
trying to figure out where my dietary
sensitivities are.
But so anyways,
that's a long answer to your question,
but I'm feeling pretty damn good.
And if I can,
I've got a few more administrative
matters that are chasing me around,
but I think I can get on top of them.
And then man,
I'm going to be back at it and that's
going to be real fun.
So,
okay,
let's see what else we got for live
questions here.
What would I say the male to female
ratio is in my classrooms currently?
Oh yeah.
There's no men man.
It's like 80% women in my psychology
classes and in 10 years there won't be a
mountain left in the humanities unless
they go online.
In which case maybe it'll only be man.
Cause I know,
I don't think so.
But most of the people who are watching
my videos are men.
It's about 90 91% actually.
So yeah,
the men are bailing out of university,
like it's just unbelievable.
And that's been happening for about 30
years.
So,
um,
it might,
if things don't change and if the
president linear trends continue,
then yeah,
it'll be all women by,
by 2025 and that's really not good.
Not that it's good,
not good because there are so many
women,
it's not good because there aren't any
men.
And obviously that's not good for the
women either,
cause I don't know where they're going
to find their men.
So.
All right.
What are your thoughts on the book of
revelation in the Bible?
It freaked me out when I was a kid.
Yeah.
Well hell I should say.
So man,
if you're an adult and you read it,
it should freak you out.
What are my thoughts on it?
I think it's a,
I think it's the,
uh,
count of a,
a hallucinogenic trip probably.
Um,
probably,
uh,
what would you call caused by silicide
mushrooms?
Maybe,
maybe I'm Anita Mascara,
um,
which were,
was identified by a guy named last saw,
uh,
about 25,
30 years ago,
maybe even more as the Soma of the
ancient Hindus.
So yeah,
I think it's a hallucination.
I think it's an account of an extremely
profound hallucinogenic trip that that's
what I think.
I mean what it means,
that's a whole different issue.
And I'm going to try to address that
when and if I get to the book of
revelations in my Biblical series,
but that's going to be probably a couple
of years in the future at the rate I'm
going because it's taken me three weeks
to get through genesis one.
So,
all right.
Violet Irwin says,
I look great while violet,
your Avatar looks great too.
Well,
thank you.
Part of the reason I look great,
I think to the degree that I do is that
I have a very good camera that my son
helped me purchase.
So it makes me look a hell of a lot
better than I actually do look.
So anyways,
I appreciate the sentiment.
All right.
Do I see any downside to a child being
raised by his father in the first three
years while the mother is working full
time?
Are there psychological consequences for
the child to be expected?
Um,
I think that depends very much on the
individual situation in the family.
Um,
I'm not convinced that the art of infant
care is something that a tremendous
number of males are highly specialized
for.
I think you have to have a feminine
temperament and that would mean to do
it,
to do infant care properly.
And that would mean that you have to be
at least very agreeable and maybe you'll
also be,
have to be relatively high in
neuroticism so that you respond rapidly
enough to the distress cries of the
child.
And I also think that in order to bond
the way that you have to bond when
you're a mother who's taking care of an
infant,
let's say under nine months,
I think some of the biochemical
transformations that accompany
pregnancy,
childbirth and lactation probably set up
the proper,
uh,
biochemical,
underlying,
biochemical and psychological mill you
that makes the kind of bonding that,
that increases the probability of high
level care possible in those few months.
That doesn't mean that men can't do it.
But I would also say in my experience
that it's kind of hard on men.
You know,
it's a complicated issue.
But like one of the things I experienced
and I really liked kits,
you know,
like I love kids and they generally
respond really well to me.
Um,
babies there are different matter
because I'm,
I don't really feel fully qualified to
give a baby what it needs.
And I guess,
you know,
that's partly because,
breastfeeding at least so far is,
is,
uh,
firmly in the domain of women.
Um,
in fact it's one of the ways by which
you could define women if we were
actually into that sort of thing.
Um,
so I think that there are circumstances
under which that's a good thing to do.
And actually I had a business partner,
have a business partner who has helped
me develop the self authoring suite.
Very smart guy named Daniel Higgins,
who's a mit engineer and also has a phd
in psychology from Harvard.
And he spent a lot of his time taking
care of his kids when they were little.
His wife was going to medical school and
he's a pretty masculine guy.
And,
uh,
it was hard on him,
man.
Like it just about killed him.
And,
I mean,
they didn't have a lot of money and she
was going through medical school and
they had two and then three little kids.
And so,
you know,
that's a very busy time of life.
But,
um,
he did it and he did a great job and he
has wonderful kids and he paid a hell of
a lot of attention to them.
But he,
it was not easy.
It was not easy for him.
And you know,
my wife,
when I watched her with our little kids
when they were infants in particular,
like she had had an affinity and a
proclivity for that sort of thing.
And my wife is actually a pretty tough
cookie.
And I wouldn't say overwhelmingly
feminine by temperament.
She's kind of disagreeable and quite
emotionally stable rather than being
agreeable and,
and high in neuroticism,
which is a more typical set of feminine
traits.
She was so damn good with infants.
It was just unbelievable.
You know?
And I do think that the biochemical
transformations that accompany pregnancy
and so forth do facilitate that.
I've also seen that with my sister who
is quite a masculine woman and very
adventurous man.
She,
uh,
she smuggled a Mercedes trucks across
the Sahara desert in the 1980s from
France down through the whole Sahara
into Niger and,
uh,
Babysat orphan gorillas in the Congo and
ran safaris through Africa.
Like she's,
she's a very adventurous person and she
took a lot after my father who's quite a
tough guy,
but you know,
she had kids when she was 40.
Luckily for her and man,
she turned into my mother overnight and
I really liked my mother,
you know,
like that's no insult.
Believe me,
she's a,
she's a really great person,
very,
very caring,
very kind,
probably to her own detriment.
But to see my sister transform into this
tough masculine person who I respected a
lot.
Um,
for exactly those virtues into,
into mum was really quite remarkable.
And to think that there's nothing
biochemical about that.
It's really,
I think,
quite naive and you know,
and pointless because of course there's
something biochemical about,
about birth and childcare for God's
sake.
It's been going on for like ever since
sexual dimorphism emerged on the
evolutionary landscape.
So that's that.
Do you think that boys in our society
are in need of a concrete transition to
man who had like a modern day initiation
ritual?
It probably doesn't matter whether
they're in need of it,
they're not going to get it.
Cause you can't really just invent
something like that.
Right.
It has to be,
it's something that evolves over a very
long period of time.
I do think that what they need,
and I really observed this interestingly
enough in the response that young men
have had to my public talks and probably
on Youtube as well with regards to what
I've been saying,
because you know,
young people have been fed this pablum
since the 1960s that the pathway to
happiness and freedom in life,
first of all,
that those are the things that you're
supposed to be after,
especially happiness and that there to
be found in,
in like rights and untrammeled freedom.
And that's complete.
Uh,
that's completely one sided because for
every right there is a corresponding
responsibility and freedom can be chaos
just as much as it can be.
Um,
you know,
blissful,
lack of responsibility and the ability
to make,
he don't act choices one after another.
And I've been speaking to young men in
particular.
They're the ones who keep coming to my
talks by the way,
about truth in action and
responsibility.
And like they're eating that up.
It's there.
I can see their eyes light up,
which is so cool.
I,
I've been talking to the people who ran
for the conservative leadership in
Canada,
um,
about the fact that when I go talk to
male audiences,
especially young men,
that they're unbelievably enthralled by
any discussion of genuine responsibility
and truth.
And so the conservatives have something
to offer young man.
And I would say that's roughly akin to
an initiation.
You know,
the idea is that at some point you have
to tell young men,
look,
grow the hell up.
Take on some responsibility,
straighten yourself out,
uh,
act honestly,
make yourself into an an admirable and
powerful character.
Not because you're
domesticated like a bloody puppy or a
sheep,
but because that's the way to genuine
authority and influence and,
and the capacity to do great good in the
world.
And that's like an exciting call to
adventure.
And I think that that's a modern,
sophisticated intellectual equivalent to
something like on initiation ritual.
And so I hope to be like promoting that
message more and more.
I was speaking to member of,
uh,
like,
one of the leaders of the indigenous
communities in Canada today about maybe
getting the high school version of the
future authoring program,
not future authoring program.
I've talked about that a bit before on
Patrion.
You know,
it's a program at self authoring Dotcom
that enables people to generate a vision
for their lives and also to,
uh,
okay.
And to detail out that vision and make a
plan of it.
I think most of you,
patriots subscribers have got links to
that already and usernames and passwords
and hasn't really remarkably positive
effect on young men who are
disenfranchised,
who tend to be ethnic minorities.
And so initiating them into the idea
that they need to take control of their
own destiny and that that's the proper
pathway to authority and stature and,
and not self esteem,
but self respect,
which is a completely different thing,
I think is a reasonable modern
equivalent to initiation ritual.
Okay,
so let's take another live question
here.
Um,
okay.
Brennan B says,
I'm halfway finished cleaning my
disaster of a room while I've got
something terrible to admit people,
because at the moment I'm sitting in my
room and it isn't clean.
The back behind here where you can see
as clean,
but because the events of the last seven
months have been so overwhelming,
I would say that there's a certain
amount of chaos that has invaded my
immediate environment.
But I have plans to get this place
sorted out in a serious way over the
next few months from top,
from bottom of the host to the talk.
So halfway Brendan,
that's a good deal.
And there's real psychological
consequences to that.
You know,
because the,
if you're interested in this,
everyone here's really sophisticated
book,
you could read,
you could take a look at Carl humans
last book,
which was called mysterium conjunction
is so that it's Latin.
Um,
now the first part of that book is
really kind of like have a dictionary of
symbolism.
He wrote it I think in his eighties,
and I think he was trying to get down as
much as he could of what he knew as fast
as he could.
So the first part is a dictionary of
symbolism and it's very difficult to
read unless you've read a lot of his
other writing.
But the second part of the book,
which I think is an absolute work of
genius,
you'll makes a couple of propositions
about higher order moral development.
And so I'm going to run through them
really quickly and,
and described their symbolism.
So he said the first thing that you want
to do if you're going to get your act
together,
um,
and this is like an extension of the,
of the Piagetian notion of,
of stages of moral development.
He said,
you know,
you have an intellect,
um,
and you have a set of emotions and
motivations and you can conceptualize
the intellect symbolically as masculine
and the emotions and motivations
symbolically as feminine.
And so the first conjunction,
which is the bringing together of the
masculine and feminine to make a
complete being,
would be the union of the intellect with
the emotions and motivations so that
you're not fighting your deeper
motivations with your thought.
You know,
that they're all moving in the same
direction.
And so that would be conjunction number
one.
And so then that makes you united in
terms of your capability for subjective
experience.
You're all pointing and all of that's
pointing in the same direction.
And it's one of the things that can make
you unstoppable because you're not at
war with yourself.
That,
and so the next conjunction as far as he
was concerned,
was also expressed symbolically.
So now you have the masculine union of
intellect,
emotion,
and motivation.
And then you have the body,
which you can now conceptualize this
feminine.
So then you bring those together in a
creative union.
And so that means that you start to act
out what you think and feel so that
there's no paradoxical relationship or
or enacted lie,
they call that a performative
contradiction between what you think and
feel and what you do.
And that's,
and so because part of being honest is
that you act out what you believe.
Right?
And so that's great.
So that's the next conjunction.
And so that makes you integrated in mind
and emotion and motivation and in
enacted,
enacted routine and body.
Great.
So that's another way of bringing
yourself together.
But the third conjunction is the one
that's most interesting and it's also
the one that's most difficult to
understand.
And that conjunction occurs when you
take this unified mind body continuum,
let's say.
And you think,
well wait a second,
there's an,
there's an element of that missing.
And that's my experience,
my experience of the world that's
hypothetically outside of me.
Or that's hypothetically not me.
Now you know,
the,
your experience of the world outside
that's not you is a very strange
experience because it isn't self
evident.
For example,
to me that my wife is not me.
We spend so much time together.
She's in my experience so much we have a
joint past and a present and a joint
future.
The same with my kids and the people who
were close to me.
It isn't obvious to me that my wife is
less valuable to me than I am to me.
She certainly more valuable to me than
some arbitrary body part,
like an arm or a leg,
you know?
And people are perfectly capable of
making gestures of physical self
sacrifice in order to rescue people that
they love.
And so just exactly who you are and just
exactly who the external world is not
clear at all.
And so the last conjunction for young
was the eradication of the distinction
between your subjective experience as
you and your object of experience as
you,
which is to say for example,
that if I'm walking down the street and
I encounter someone in trouble and that
trouble calls to me as something that I
could conceivably do something about.
The fact that that trouble isn't sat
right in the world is actually is
actually because it's part of my
experience is actually my problem.
Now,
that doesn't mean that it's my fault,
although it might be,
might not be.
Perhaps it isn't,
but it might be,
but it's still my responsibility and
it's reasonable to consider the
disruption in my experiential field than
encountering someone who is in trouble,
produces as an actual disturbance in my,
in my being,
and then to act as if it's my
responsibility to rectify that
disturbance.
Now the problem of course comes in that
you don't know how.
So if you run across a street alcoholic,
for example,
in the middle of the day and they're
stumbling wrong blindly and maybe their
schizophrenia to boot and mumbling
terrible things,
you know it's going to disturb you and
it would be good if you could set it
right,
but you don't know how.
So you can't,
you have to avoid it.
But that doesn't mean that that isn't
you because it's also you.
And I think that's why in the story of
the Buddha,
for example,
like the Buddha was basically offered
when he became enlightened,
the chance to remain in Nirvana,
right as a uniquely enlightened,
singular individual.
And he actually regret rejected that
offer because it was his deepest
conviction that it was,
it was not possible for one person to be
enlightened and to be in a state of
Nevada if everyone wasn't in that state
at the same time.
And so he had to move himself out of
that Utopian experience of Nirvana and
come back to the normal world,
let's say.
And to try to raise the consciousness of
people around him because he regarded
that as unfinished business.
That was his personally.
And so
now
I don't remember who was I.
Oh yes.
That's all about cleaning your room.
You have six actually,
so,
well,
the thing is,
is that your,
your room isn't,
not you.
Yeah,
it's actually you.
Yeah.
And so there's no difference between the
chaos that's outside of you in a place
that you spend as much time as you spend
in your room and the chaos that's
internal psychologically.
And you know,
one of the things I often do when I'm
first dealing with my clients as a
simple exercise in setting themselves,
right psychologically,
is to have them start to clean up their
external environment.
Because if people know how to do that,
and there's no difference between that
and putting yourself straight
psychologically as you know,
when you do something as serious as
starting to clean up or your omen.
So Brendan,
the other thing I would say is like
finish cleaning your room and then see
if you can make it beautiful because
that's also unbelievably useful man,
because it teaches you about beauty.
And so then you can make one room in
your house beautiful.
And then it's organized and together and
beautiful.
And so once you do that with one room,
like you're way wiser than you were
before and you've actually accomplished
something concrete that's solid and in
controvertible that you can point to
that strengthens your character.
And then maybe you can do the same thing
with your whole house.
And then maybe you can do that with the
more with the world around you.
And believe me,
if you start doing that,
you're not going to be sitting around
wondering what the meaning of life is,
because you're going to find it in that.
So,
all right,
so let's see.
MMM.
Max and mark says,
thoughts on the Jews.
Well,
that's complicated.
Most of them,
most of my friends are Jews,
which is pretty interesting,
you know,
and when I grew up in northern Alberta
and there were no Jews up there at all,
so,
um,
it coming out to eastern Canada,
especially Montreal,
there were lots of Jewish people there.
And I made friends with lots of them.
And then in,
in Toronto,
like,
and I said,
I think part of the reason that so many
of my friends have been Jewish is
because the Jews have,
you know,
and I'm obviously speaking in a very
general sense,
is they have a rich intellectual life
and tremendous respect for,
for intellectual pursuits.
And so we have a natural affinity.
And so,
um,
you know,
more power to them as far as I'm
concerned.
There's a fair,
there's a fair bit of evidence,
especially with regards to the Ashkenazi
Jews that they,
they're,
they're average Iq is or about 15 points
higher than the general population,
which accounts in part for the radical
overrepresentation among Nobel prize
winners for example.
And also in positions of let's say
authority and responsibility in many
different domains.
And it's like,
man,
I'm not unhappy about successful people.
It's like,
as I said,
it's the same in relationship to money
as far as I'm concerned.
It's not that you have a position of
authority and I'm not going to say power
because power and authority aren't the
same thing,
but if you have a position of authority,
what is what you do with it.
And so if competent people occupy
positions of authority,
then more power to them.
That's lucky for the rest of us.
I'll tell you that.
So,
um,
and I think,
you know,
I've often thought this about the Jews
too,
is that if you're going to be a
minority,
you should at least have the decency to
fail.
And I think that part of the reason,
because you know,
then,
well,
you're around and you're annoying
because you're a minority.
And you know,
because people are fundamentally a
ethnocentric and all human beings are
like that.
But if a minority fails,
then why you can say,
well at least they failed.
And you know,
that may be lousy,
not to hate them quite as much,
but the Jews have this annoying
proclivity where they go as a minority
to become extremely successful.
And of course nobody can stand that.
And so that's a huge part of what
accounts for antisemitism,
which are regarded as an absolutely.
I know a bismal and,
and,
and uh,
what would you call it?
Reprehensible.
A Priori stats,
you know.
So that's some of my thoughts about
them.
Anyways.
All right,
next.
How did I meet my wife?
And why did you marry her?
Oh,
well I'll tell you one of the earliest
memories I have my wife,
cause it kind of tells me what she's
like,
Eh.
So she lived across the street from me
in this little town that we grew up in
called fairview,
Alberta.
And I think I fell in love with her the
moment that I saw her and I,
although I don't think the feeling was
necessarily mutual.
And so I was about like seven I think,
something like that.
So I've known her for like 48 years.
And here's one memory because this is
their two memories,
I'll tell you.
So one of them was when I was in grade
five I got glasses and I was pretty
proud of these classes.
They were horn rimmed glasses,
you know,
and I was pretty proud of them.
And I went out and I,
she came out onto the street and she
looked at my glasses.
I said,
what are you thinking of that was,
and she says,
I think you look really funny in those.
And then she pointed at me and ran into
her house.
And it wasn't like 20 years later that
she finally told me that she had always
wanted to have glasses and she was
jealous about it,
but you know,
she decided she'd give me a good teasing
and a good poke.
And so that,
and then we used to play croquet
together.
And one of the great delights she would
take is,
I don't know if you've ever laid
croquet,
but you know,
you're sometimes the one person's ball
that they're hitting and another
person's will come together and then you
can stand on your ball and you can nail
it with the croquet mallet and like
knock the other person's,
um,
croquet ball halfway down the block.
And she used to think that was pretty
damn amusing when she did it to me.
So,
and,
uh,
let's see,
what else can I remember about her that
was,
but yeah,
I mean,
I told my dad when I was in grade five,
I was sitting with her on this big
armchair in our living room,
and she was sitting beside me on the arm
chair,
which I was pretty damn thrilled about.
And she was being chased around by all
the boys in the school at that point,
even though she,
that was in the elementary school,
you know,
so she was very,
uh,
hot property,
let's say,
among the elementary school boys.
And so I was pretty happy to have her
sit by me.
And so anyway,
she left and I told my dad that I was
going to marry her
and,
uh,
I remember that and he told that story
at our wedding,
which was quite cute.
And then I'll tell you one more story,
which I really think it's funny.
This is so funny.
So we,
we were friends when we were kids and
then,
you know,
girls mature faster than boys and she's
a year older than me cause I skipped a
grade in school.
We were in the same grade in school.
And so,
you know,
when she hit about 13 or so,
we kind of went our separate ways a
little bit,
although we still remained friends and
she had a paper route and I took her
paper route over when she hit 13 or so
and I like quadrupled the damn thing,
I think,
which I think is pretty funny.
But,
um,
I also delivered paper to her house and,
one day she was there with a number
other of her friends and,
uh,
who was,
kind of a cute chick too.
And I liked her quite a bit and they
were sitting around talking about like
talking about how they were,
uh,
feminists,
roughly speaking.
And they were talking when I walked in
about the fact that neither of them are
going to take their husbands last day
when they got married.
And,
uh,
Tammy,
my wife,
I think said to her friend,
while that really means I'm going to
have to find some wimp and marry him.
And she turned around and looked at me
and smiled evilee and said,
Hey Jordan,
do you want to get married?
And of course I'd heard the whole
conversation and you know,
she knew I liked her obviously.
And so that was nice little comical.
Desc she has a very vicious sense of
humor and,
you know,
I kind of laughed and I thought,
how,
okay,
yeah.
Okay,
so fine.
So then
what we were,
I was like 28 and she had come to see me
in Montreal and,
um,
we were talking about getting married
and she said,
we were talking about what that would
mean.
And then we started talking about what
the name would be.
And I said,
Hey,
I've got a story for you.
Um,
you remember when you were 13 and I was
delivering papers to your house.
And,
uh,
cause I suggested that she take my last
name and she wasn't so sure about that.
And I said,
well,
you remember that little story,
that little episode that we had when you
were 13 and I came over to your house
and you told me that you weren't going
to take your husband's name and that
you're going to have to marry some wimp.
Said,
okay,
well,
you know,
here I am,
but you know,
if we're going to get married,
you're going to take my name.
And that's the end of that argument.
And so,
you know,
she had the good graces to go along with
that,
but that was actually,
you know,
stored nearly comical and ridiculous.
So,
um,
so yeah,
so that's a good one.
What's my advice to young men seeking a
woman for marriage and family?
Yeah.
Well,
okay,
fine.
That's the same question.
Second question.
That's,
that's pretty straight forward,
man.
I mean,
you can't eliminate the necessity of
being attracted to one another.
That's important.
And that's mysterious,
you know?
Um,
so for example,
here's a funny thing.
If you,
one of the
things we know that attracts people to
one another is bilateral symmetry.
And so if you take men and you ranked
them by the symmetry of their faces,
and then you give the asymmetrical men
tee shirts to wear clean t shirts for a
day and the symmetrical men clean t
shirts to wear for a day.
And then you give the tee shirts to
women and you have them rate the odor,
the women rate the odor of the
symmetrical men as more attractive than
the odor of the asymmetrical men.
And then,
and there were other,
uh,
factors that determined sexual
attractiveness that are based on
biological factors that are so deeply
embedded in terms of smell,
for example.
So,
uh,
women also tend to,
not be sexually attracted to the,
to the scent of men whose,
who have,
if I remember correctly,
it's rh factors that would make for
potential trouble in childbirth.
And the often,
the reason that the women give for not
preferring the scent of those men is
that they smell too much like their
brother,
something like that.
So there was weird,
mysterious things that determine whether
or not people are sexually and
physically attracted to each other.
And I think it's very important that
that's part of a marital relationship.
The next most important thing is trust
man.
It's like there's no marriage that
successful without trust you guys.
You got to tell each other the truth.
And one of the reasons that you don't
believe that marriage as an an an oath
and Carl Jung as a bond was necessary.
It's really wise.
It's like,
you know,
telling the truth to someone is no
simple thing because there's a bunch of
things about all of us that are terrible
and weak and reprehensible and shameful
and all of those things and they kind of
have to be brought out into the open and
dealt with.
And you're not going to tell the truth
about yourself to someone who can run
away screaming when you reveal who you
are.
And so the,
the marriage bond is something like,
okay,
here's the deal.
I'm going to handcuff myself to you and
you're going to handcuff yourself to me.
And then we're going to tell each other
the truth and neither of us are going to
get to run away.
And so are,
once we know the truth,
then we're either going to live together
in mutual torment or we're going to try
to deal with that truth and straighten
ourselves out and street in ourselves,
out jointly.
And that's going to make us more
powerful and more resilient and more and
deeper and wiser as we progress together
through life.
And,
and I think that's absolutely brilliant
because if you leave the backdoor open
mat and you're going to use it,
that's for sure.
And the oath is there.
And this was young's commentary on the
spiritualization of,
of the human pair boy and by Christian
marriage for example,
which,
which emphasized,
uh,
the,
what would you call it,
the subordination of both members of the
marital union to a higher order,
ah,
personality that embodied in the figure
of the logos.
So the idea is that an an an an an in
the Christian marriage for example,
the man isn't the boss and the woman
isn't the boss.
The boss is the mutual personality
composed by the seeking of truth in both
of them and that's conceptualized as
theirs,
their joint subjugation to the logos.
And that is absolutely dead on man.
It's like the ruler of your marital life
should be your vows to tell each other
the truth because like in hard times
during your life when you've done
something stupid and idiotic,
that might take you down and you don't
have anybody that you can turn to,
you know,
if you have a partner that you can
trust,
you can go say,
hey,
you know I made a big financial mistake
man and it's really torturing me and I
feel like a complete idiot and it's
really dangerous.
And the person there,
it's going to help you figure out what
to do about it.
And they're going to know that when they
make a stupid mistake and they're bloody
well going to that they can come and
talk to you and that you guys are going
to work your way through it.
And that's a big deal.
And there's a couple of things our
culture gets really wrong and one is it
devalues marriage.
That's really a very bad idea because
marriages,
marriages like a third of your life and
maybe more and kids are a third of your
life and your,
your,
your life outside of marriage and kids
is a third of your life,
you know,
approximately speaking and to miss any
of that is a massive,
massive mistake.
Now,
having said that,
I will also say that for some people,
missing one or more of those is
necessary because they have a reason.
You know,
maybe they're brilliantly creative
artists and they need to devote
themselves entirely to their career or
their outstanding in some way.
And so they need,
they can justify the sacrifice of one
part of that tryout of being to another
part but for,
but generally speaking it's a very
dangerous thing and it,
it,
it shouldn't be duct.
And also kids get an absolutely terrible
rap,
you know,
because kids are delightful if they're
well behaved.
One of the chapters in my new book is
called don't let your children do
anything that makes you dislike them and
you can do that.
Especially if you discuss it thoroughly
with your spouse.
You're the person that's helping you
discipline the kids and children are the
best company because they're really
enthusiastic about everything.
They love doing new things.
They really love you so they're happy
that you're around.
Um,
all you have to do is make sure they're
not too hot and they're not too cold and
they've had something to eat and they're
not too tired and you don't expect them
to stay engaged in something for longer
than they can manage.
Because we used to take our kids when
they were little out to restaurants for
example.
And they could sit there and no problem
and behave really nicely when they were
two and three,
but they couldn't do it for more than
about 45 minutes.
He can't push your luck.
But I also noticed with little kids is
that they got antsy and unreasonable
about five to 10 minutes before the
adults did too.
It's just the adults were too stupid to
notice.
The kids would notice right away.
So,
um,
so back to while you look for someone
that you're attracted to,
that you love,
and then you look for someone that you
can bloody well trust and then you tell
them the truth and,
and that way maybe you can get through
life and you can have someone to weave
the rope of your being with and together
to make,
to make your joint ropes stronger.
And you can have some continuity in your
narrative and you can have children.
And then you can have grandchildren and
like you can have a life man and there's
nothing.
You're so fortunate if you can manage
that.
And so,
okay,
so there's that one.
So what's my advice to young men seeking
a woman for marriage and family?
Yeah.
Well,
and also,
you know,
marry someone you think would be a good
mother and that has enough sense
generally speaking,
to know that she wants children.
Now some women don't want children and
fair enough and some women perhaps
shouldn't have children.
That's also possible.
But the general rule of thumb is,
especially once a woman's,
you know,
inner mid twenties,
if she doesn't know that she wants
children or won't admit it,
unless she has a viciously important
reason,
then she's not oriented properly.
Psychologically she,
she,
she isn't,
she doesn't know what's important in
life.
Now that might also be the case with you
and it probably is,
but as a rule of thumb,
that's a really good one.
So,
okay,
another more spontaneous one here.
Oh,
right.
Um,
on the other hand,
what's your advice to high achieving
females for finding a man?
That's a,
that's a tough one.
Do I want to do I want to answer that
question?
See the problem that high achieving
women have.
And I've dealt with a lot of them,
you know,
because one of the,
first of all I've have a clinical
practice as most of you may know,
and I also had a consulting practice and
one of the things they were kind of
mixed,
but one of the things I did for a long
time was I served as a consultant to two
people who were spectacularly successful
in their careers because I worked with
an agency whose sales pitch basically to
the companies or the law firms because
it was mostly law firms was give us your
really high achieving people and we'll
help them sort out their lives even more
and make them even more productive and
valuable than they already are.
And you don't need much of an increment
in the value of someone who's high
achieving to justify that from an
economic perspective.
So I work with a lot of high achieving
people for like 15 years and I still do
it to some degree.
And Lot of them were women and a lot of
them were female lawyers.
And they were very interesting to work
with because most of them were extremely
attractive and they were very,
very smart and they were tough.
Um,
and you know,
they were very demanding when it came to
a,
because women do tend to mate across and
up dominance hierarchies.
And if you're like very attractive and
you're very intelligent and you make a
lot of money and you're very competent,
it's like there's not a lot that's
across and there's even less that's up.
And so that's hard on women.
And,
and it actually,
the way,
the way that that actually works out is
that,
especially with regards to Iq for women,
is that the higher the Iq that a woman
has,
the less likely it is that she's going
to find a partner and they effect is
actually quite pronounced.
And so that's pretty rough.
What's my advice?
Well,
the first piece of advice probably would
be,
don't pretend that it's not important
because it is important.
And the next piece of advice I would say
is,
and this is practically speaking,
is it's a lot easier now for people to
find at least a potential partner than
it was 20 years ago because you have
this tremendous technology that's
available with regards to opening up the
dating market.
And I would say finding the right mate
is like finding a good career,
the next good career move.
I know that's not a great analogy,
but a huge part of that is just
persistence.
You have to kiss a lot of frogs before
you find a prince,
you know?
I suppose that's one way of thinking
about it.
And then,
and then I guess I would also say
that's really about the best I can do,
man.
It's,
it's a,
it's a really complicated question.
Look for someone that loves you and that
wants to take care of you and that,
and that is oriented to some degree
towards the same things that you are,
that's also helpful.
But apart from the earlier things I said
about attractiveness and truth,
you know,
that's about the best I can do.
It's a very complicated question.
Okay.
Kenny Lauderdale.
Yeah,
this is a good one.
How do I get over my fear of driving?
I'm an adult and have no driver's
license and it's crippling.
Meet ma'am.
That's a really important question.
A lot of young adults,
and I don't know if you're younger,
not,
um,
don't have their driver's license.
And I think that's a catastrophe because
it's a real,
first of all,
it's,
it's economically suicidal because it
makes it very difficult night if you
live in New York City or somewhere like
that.
But you know,
if you live anywhere else,
you sacrifice your autonomy by not being
able to drive.
Look,
uh,
Kenny,
I would say take a driver's course and
do it badly.
It's,
who cares if you have to do it five
times,
you know,
go sit in a car for a while and pretend
to drive like you're a kid and then have
them drive you around the block and like
take it slow.
Maybe it's something that'll take you a
whole year to learn,
but you're,
you're actually in a really good
situation to advance yourself
psychologically because you know that
there's something you should do that's
learned to drive,
right.
That's challenging and you know that
it's interfering with you.
So you have a great opportunity right
there to overcome that and to improve
your psychological functioning.
And I would say this is associated with
the Tarot card.
The fool,
if you look up that card,
you'll see that the fool is often a
young man who's about in sunny day,
who's about to step off a cliff.
You think,
well,
is that a good Carter,
a bad card?
It's like the symbolic meaning of that
card is that in order to make progress,
you have to be a fool.
And you know you've already admitted
you're a fool,
you're afraid,
and you don't know how to drive.
Like you know how pathetic.
Hahaha.
Yeah.
Okay.
The thing is you accept that is you
don't know what you're doing and you're
going to be a fool while you're doing
it.
And,
but you're no where near as much of a
fool doing it as a fool than you are as
a fool avoiding it.
So I would say go find someone
professionally that can teach you how to
drive.
Find someone that's patient,
tell them that you're nervous about it.
Start in a parking lot that's empty on
an early Sunday,
more sunny Sunday morning.
You know,
where you're not going to kill anybody
and get your damn driver's license.
It'll do you and unbelievably it'll do.
It'll do you a tremendous amount of
good.
So,
so great.
You know,
you say there's this old,
uh,
Al Chemical saying that Carl Jung was
very fond of which is [inaudible],
which means something like in filth,
it will be found or it means what you
most want is where you to be found,
where you eat at least one look and you
know where you least bought.
Look man,
you don't want to look at your ability
as a driver.
So go fix that.
And it'll really help you out,
man.
Tanner spell and he suggestions for
someone about to start university.
Yeah.
Um,
see if you can find some professors.
They're going to be often going to be
older people and often older guys who
still know what the classic scholars
knew and stay away from the bloody
postmodernists.
Like you might want to take a course
just so you know what that sort of thing
is about.
But see if you can find people who are
literate,
really literate and who can teach you.
And so what you do is you shop around,
go to classes more than more classes
than you can take at least in the first
couple of weeks of university.
Listen to the professors and find out
the ones that are telling you something
that you really need to know and then
follow them and stick with them.
So you have to search out your own path
to be educated in university.
The other thing I would say is make a
schedule.
Treat university like it's a fulltime
job.
Make a schedule the first week of
classes.
Put in your exams,
like in Google calendar.
Put in your assignments,
make a plan to,
um,
to make the,
to get the assignments done.
Start early because lots of kids end up
by Thanksgiving the first semester and
they get so damn far behind,
they can't believe it.
Cause there's a lot of work in
university,
a lot of reading,
and then they bail out.
Don't make that mistake,
man.
It's like,
it's a full time job.
And then you can go have fun at night,
you know,
and more power to you.
Go have fun,
figure out what your responsibilities
are,
lay them out and make a plan and then
stay on top of them.
And then you know,
you'll,
you'll do yourself a great favor.
So.
Okay.
Um,
with the majority of your audience being
men,
how would you characterize the few women
that are generally interested in your
videos?
Does it mean their masculine side might
be preeminent?
I don't know the answer to that mean
it's the thing,
it's tough one because it turns out that
my primary audiences on youtube and
youtube seems to be a place that's where
men are hanging out more than women.
Now.
I don't know why that is.
It might be because men are slightly
more interested in nonfiction and in
ideas per se than women who are more
interested in is fedex and fiction.
That's how what the personality data
reveals.
And so it might be that because youtube
is,
has kind of an emphasis on,
on ideas per se and non fiction ideas
that men more gravitate towards it.
Although that is against,
believe me,
cause I don't really understand it.
Um,
are the women who are watching me more
masculine in their orientation?
It's possible.
Okay.
I'm not,
so it's not self evident to me why that
should be the case though,
because I also spend a lot of time
talking about symbolic issues and,
and aesthetics would you think would be
attractive to women.
So I actually don't know the answer to
that.
So,
um,
what should I do if every time I
voluntarily confront my problems,
I get too overwhelmed with stress to
make progress solving them.
Ah,
that's a good one,
man.
Okay.
So the first thing is take your
problems.
Like let's say that,
let's take the driving example.
I'm too afraid to drive.
Okay.
Then you think,
well,
what exactly does driving consist of?
Well,
the first thing is,
is that you have to establish some kind
of relationship with a car.
So you might think,
well,
you're not too afraid to go online and
do a little investigation into what cars
are like,
like what's a good car and how do they
work?
And you know,
the familiarize yourself with the car
and then that makes you less afraid.
And then you think,
well maybe I'll just go sit out in the
car and put my hands on the steering
wheel.
And you don't just kind of accustomed
myself to the idea of being in the car
and a customize accustom myself in my
imagination.
Drive around in the car and maybe I'll
try some driving simulators online.
And then,
then the next thing is,
well maybe I can find someone I can
trust to train me.
And what we'll do is,
as I mentioned earlier,
is we'll go out to an empty parking lot
on a Sunday morning and I'll drive 15
feet and then stop.
And that'll be good enough for the day.
So what you want to do if you're
overwhelmed with your problems is you
want to break the problems down and you
and you do this by thinking
strategically.
You want to break the problems down into
units that are small enough so that you
can confront them and master them with a
high degree of probability.
And you know,
you can decompose almost every stressful
problem into.
So imagine that you have a stack of
paper on your desk and there's a bunch
of monsters inside it that you don't
want to face.
You know,
like homework you haven't done or taxes
that you haven't finished your or,
or you know,
trouble you're having with a
bureaucratic enterprise that you'd
rather avoid.
It's like one of the things you can do
is just the first day you might think,
okay Jesus,
I want to avoid that.
All right,
well would I be willing to take the
papers downstairs and put them on the
table and spend no more than 10 minutes
just looking at them and organizing them
and you might add then you ask yourself,
what would I do that?
And if the answer is yes,
you think,
okay,
that'll be good enough for today.
And then the thing is,
you've knocked on the dragon store,
you know,
and,
and you've,
you've,
you've eliminated the first part of the
avoidance.
And so then you're on your way and the
next day you might think,
well,
you know,
could I deal with the first page of that
problem?
And you think,
wow,
I could at least look at it.
And the trick is,
and this was what behavioral
psychologists do all the time,
is identify the fear,
break it down into its sub components,
lay out a schedule for confronting the
sub components and don't burden yourself
more than you can tolerate.
And Man,
you can make unbelievable progress that
way.
But you know,
you have to be willing to give yourself
credit for small achievements.
And that's fine because consistent small
achievements add up incrementally across
time into absolutely remarkable progress
because it's,
it starts to,
uh,
you start to get like compound interest
in it on it.
So,
yeah,
so that's what you should do.
And look,
if that doesn't work and you're so
overwhelmed that you're just absolutely
in spaces,
then one of the things that you should
consider is that maybe you have an
anxiety disorder,
maybe you're depressed.
Like maybe things have just really
collapsed in on you and you have
terrible problems.
Like,
you know,
maybe you're sick and you're,
you have an ill relative and you're in
real financial trouble and you're
unemployed.
It's like,
that's just too much.
And so at that point,
maybe you need to go talk to someone and
maybe you need to consider something
like temporary antianxiety medication or
antidepressant medication and to sit
down and strategize with someone about
how you're going to put your life back
on track.
And I would say also,
if you're in a situation like that and
you can't find a,
okay,
you can't find a therapist,
then try the self authoring program
because that's what we designed it for.
So,
okay,
another live one.
Let's see here.
MMM.
I saw someone called the green bastard.
I wanted to answer that question,
but it flashed by real quick.
So is that a reference to bubbles'
wrestling persona?
Uh,
just out of curiosity,
I'm wondering if you're a fellow trailer
park boys fan because I,
you know,
I love the trailer park boys and,
and uh,
because of my western Canadian
upbringing I suppose.
And,
um,
so,
but I missed your question,
but I like your,
uh,
your handle,
so,
okay.
Let's see.
Oh,
Mohammed had,
how do you says re Islam?
Can I send you names of us Canadians,
scholars who are grounded in western
culture and traditional Islam?
You should reach out to them before I
entered her z.
Do sure.
Do it,
man.
Send it Jordan Dot Peterson at U
Toronto.
Dot.
Ca.
I already talked to I and Hirsi Ali,
by the way,
and I'm going to post my discussion with
her very soon,
but I am,
I'm interested in,
um,
engaging in as broad a series of
dialogues as possible.
And so if you've got some people you
think are good and articulate and
willing to talk,
man,
yeah,
send their names.
Okay.
Jordan Dot Peterson at U Toronto.
Dot.
Ca.
Um,
let's see.
Dr. Peterson.
I was wondering if you have any advice
for figuring out whether vengeance is
ever a good thing or is it always bad?
Oh,
that's a good one,
man.
Look,
I have clients very frequently who have
been seriously wronged by someone in
their life and maybe the wrong doing is
ongoing and so like they're often
possessed by the desire for revenge
sometimes to homicide levels.
Okay.
So then you got to think about that
really carefully because you know,
you say,
well,
you should forgive people.
It's like,
well
no,
you should forgive people that repent.
Yeah.
And you should forgive people because be
carrying the burden of the demand for
vengeance with you and being resentful
about that is really hard on you and it
can cripple you.
And so it's not a great move
psychologically.
But having said that,
like it's not easy to distinguish the
demand,
the desire for vengeance from the desire
for justice.
And part of the reason that we have a
justice system is so that you can
outsource your desire for vengeance to
assist them.
That alleviates your moral
responsibility for,
okay,
going head to head with someone that's
wrong.
Do you?
So it's a really complicated question
and I would say,
I can't answer it on a generic level.
I'd have to say it depends on the
particulars of your situation.
But vengeance,
the problem with vengeance generally
speaking,
is that it produces
mmm
feuds.
Like it spirals out of control.
You know,
I hit you,
you hit me twice,
I hate you four times,
you stab me,
you know,
I kill your brother,
you killed my family,
you know,
and then soon the whole world's at war.
And it's something,
I think that the story of Cain and Abel
really
okay
warns against.
And I think part of the reason that we
have a justice system is actually to
stop people from taking vengeance on
each other.
So you know the demand.
You remember years ago,
Michael Mactac to Cactus,
I think that was his name.
He ran for president.
And one of the things he did that was
really wrong is that when he was
governor of Massachusetts,
he released this guy,
I think his name was willy,
if I remember correctly.
And once he was released,
he went out,
raped someone.
If,
if I've got the story right and Dukakis
was asked,
asked on national TV,
you know,
how,
how he would respond,
something like that if someone had raped
his wife,
like someone who was released,
had raped his wife,
you know,
and the right response to that question
is,
you know,
I'd like to rip the guy's lungs out and
maybe I'd stalk his house until I had
the opportunity to do that.
That's what I would want to do.
But because I'm a civilized person and I
understand the danger of that,
I would cooperate with the justice
system and do everything I could to
ensure that the person was brought to
justice.
And then I would do my best to reconcile
myself without outcome,
even though every cell in my body would
be crying out for vengeance.
That's the right answer.
But,
well,
so I'll leave that,
the answer to that.
Um,
I'll leave.
I'll leave it at that.
So
yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's see.
Um,
I'd like to take good big five test.
I've noticed there are many online.
Where can I find the most accurate test
to take?
Well,
I would say wait three weeks or a month
because we're going to release our
version of the big five aspect scale,
which is a scale that,
that,
that a student of mine called the young
developed while he was working in my
lab.
And,
um,
it was partly generated by an idea that
I had with,
uh,
another,
my business partner I mentioned earlier,
Daniel Higgins.
Cause we had talked for years about the
necessity of developing a more
differentiated higher resolution version
of the big five,
which had been attempted by the people
who,
uh,
develop the neo pir,
which has a,
which has,
what did they call them?
Facets,
but they weren't empirically derived.
So if you wait a month,
you'd be able to take the big five
aspects scale test and it would give you
10 dimensions of personality output.
And I think it's a,
it's a really good test.
We've used it a lot and it's being used
very widely in the relevant scientific
domains.
The papers be very highly cited.
I think it's been cited like 600 times
or something like that.
So,
so,
um,
keep an eye out and that should be
coming real soon.
So if psychedelics increase openness and
openness is correlated with
intelligence,
can psychedelics increase intelligence?
Good question.
I doubt it.
Most things don't increase fluid
intelligence really hard to get an
increase in fluid intelligence.
Um,
you know,
those brain training games like
lumosity,
um,
even if you play a lot of those games
and they're very complex cognitive
games,
you don't tend to experience an increase
in general intelligence.
You get better at each game domain
specifically,
but it doesn't seem to generalize across
intelligence per se.
So,
um,
I doubt that psychedelics increase
intelligence and openness,
the personality dimension.
See,
it's a good question because it might be
that psychedelic use would increase
something like divergent thinking
associated with like the torrance tests
of creativity.
But I don't think anybody's ever tested
that.
And you could consider that a form of
intelligence,
but I think the probability that it
would increase,
um,
nonverbal intelligence is low.
MMM.
And that's partly because there are
elements to openness that aren't
reducible to psychometric intelligence.
So I doubt it.
It would be wonderful if we could find
something that would increase
intelligence,
but that's turned out to be something
unbelievably difficult.
Um,
okay.
To what extent do you believe that
discourse with moderate Muslims can lead
to reform of the ideology such that the
gap between Islamic and Western beliefs
can be bridged?
Well,
I guess we're going to find out about
that because that's one of the things I
want to do over the next couple of
years.
Um,
it's,
you know,
I said this before,
um,
but I think it's worth saying again,
as far as I can tell,
there's only three states of being there
is tyranny,
there's slavery and there's negotiation
and you know,
tyranny,
tyranny and slavery are forms of war.
So we either enter into discourse and
hopefully with the moderate Muslims or
yeah,
where are the tyrants or they're the
tyrants and we're the slaves,
or they're the slaves.
And then there's war.
And so we bloody well better have
discourse because war is what happens
when discourse fails.
And you know,
we actually,
in some ways,
we can't really go to war anymore
because we're so armed.
And increasingly that's also the case in
the Muslim world.
I mean,
look at Pakistan,
it's,
it's developing a pretty decent nuclear
arm.
Our movement,
I'm nuclear a deterrent let's say,
which is quite terrifying because
Pakistan is one unstable and dangerous
place.
But I mean,
what are you going to do?
You're going to go to war with people
who have hydrogen bombs.
It's like,
that's not gonna work out very well.
So we bloody well better learn to talk.
And so I'm hoping,
you know,
I'm doing this biblical series,
which some of you may be no about
because you're also helping to ensure
that it happened.
And again,
thank you very much.
But in parallel without,
I'm doing,
I want to do a very long series of
discussions with moderate Muslims,
theological,
philosophical,
political,
practical to see if the gap between
Islamic and western beliefs can be
bridged.
I better be able to be bridged because
we're all on the same planet,
man.
And there's lots of both of us.
So,
um,
capitulation on either side isn't going
to work and,
and like blind ignorance of the,
of the dangers,
mutual dangers that our society's post
to one another.
I mean,
I mean by that I mean,
you know,
to the degree that Islam,
Islamic societies are functional
traditional societies,
they're threatened in that functional
traditionalism by radical western
technological and philosophical
revolution,
just like worth threatened as Westerners
ourselves by our own technological and
philosophical,
revolutionary nature discourse,
truthful
discourse,
man.
That's,
that's the hope for the salvation of the
world.
And so hopefully we'll put it into
practice.
I've,
I've met a number of moderate Muslims
already in Canada who are extremely
interested in this sort of thing and
some in the u s as well.
And so I think that,
well,
you know,
it's worth a try,
man.
So,
okay,
another live one
just tuned in says logic bombs.
How many times should I clean my room?
Clean your room until when you go in
there,
you start doing things that are good for
you.
So because cleaning it isn't just isn't
just organ,
it's not just making sure that it's not
messy man.
It's organizing it so that it's a place
where you're being can properly manifest
itself.
It's a place that should invite you to
do the things that are good for you in
the world and show you should be
thinking when you have a room.
If you're fortunate and I have to have a
room,
you think,
okay,
I want to organize this room so that the
probability that all do the things that
I know I should do as maximumly
heightened,
you know,
get yourself good desk.
If you need a desk,
get yourself a good bed that you liked,
like set the bloody place up so that
when you walk in there,
you think,
Jesus,
a civilized human being could really
live in here.
And then every time you walk in there,
your room,
we'll remind you that the proper way to
behave in there is to behave as a
civilized,
being responsible,
intelligent,
forward looking,
articulate,
you know,
concerned about doing what's good in,
in the most courageous and and
responsible possible way.
You know,
not as a two bit do gooder,
who's looked trying to look good in
front of the world,
but as someone who's tough and,
and,
and able and,
and caring and reliable and all of that,
and that's what your room should tell
you.
So set the damn thing up until that's
what it screams at you when you walk in
there.
So,
okay,
what is my Iq?
Less than it used to be because it
declines as you age,
you know,
quite a lot.
So you start getting stupider from an Iq
perspective at about 22 or 23.
So,
and the best way to regulate that is to
engage in physical exercise.
Just so you all know.
So,
um,
both weightlifting and cardiovascular
exercise are really good for the
maintenance of intelligence.
Um,
I don't know what my Iq is.
I,
I had it tested at one point.
MMM.
It's in excess of 150,
but I don't know exactly where it lands
now.
I should,
uh,
what qualify that to some degree,
you know,
as your intelligence increases,
the scatter between the different
subtypes of intelligence such as there
are increases.
So you might say that there's only one
way to be stupid,
but there's many ways to be intelligent.
And so I'm not overwhelmingly
intelligent from a quantitative
perspective.
You know,
I think my gre scores for on the
quantitative,
uh,
end of things for about 70,
75th percentile,
which isn't too bad given that,
you know,
you're competing against other people
who were going into graduate school,
but there's a big difference between
75th percentile and 99th percentile.
And I think that's where it was
verbally,
something like that.
Um,
so I can certainly see that I have gaps
in my intelligence when it,
when I'm discussing things with people
who have real,
who are really quantitatively brilliant.
My business partner,
Daniel Higgins is quantitatively
brilliant.
Um,
I've got an edge on a verbally,
but,
but he's definitely got an edge on me
quantitatively.
And I've had students like that too,
who like could pick up statistics.
I had one student who was little on the
artistic side that,
that she is a woman man,
not woman.
She was so damn smart sheet.
She learned how to write,
moved from,
you know,
credible writer to an excellent writer
and about four months,
which was stellar.
And she moved from not knowing a damn
thing about statistics to being able to
teach it to Harvard undergraduates had
an award winning level within a year.
It's like that just made my jaw drop.
Now she had a hell of a time presenting
herself properly in public when she was
doing public presentations.
So,
you know,
she had other gaps in her ability.
But um,
you know,
I can hold my own verbally and I'm
rarely in a situation where I feel like
I'm at a disadvantage verbally,
but that's certainly not the case
quantitatively.
I feel at a disadvantage very
frequently,
quantitatively.
So,
um,
I would love to hear you do a lecture
series on raising children properly.
Is that something you would consider?
Um,
yeah.
we'll see.
You know,
I'm really curious to see what sort of
response this book I'm going to publish
gets,
especially this chapter on,
don't let your children do anything that
makes you dislike them.
Because in some sense I would say that
the propositions I put forth aren't
exactly what you would normally here,
surprise,
surprise in,
in the cultural milieu that surrounds
children right now because everybody and
their dog is afraid of disciplining
children.
And that's really stupid because,
yeah,
stupid.
His rights,
the right word.
Because undisciplined children are
terrified and the reason they're
terrified as they,
sorry.
Gotta change the battery.
Yeah.
And
hopefully we're back.
Let's see.
Okay.
Um,
Mr Cuban says,
why is it so important to have kids if
the world has an overpopulation problem?
Well,
who says the world has an overpopulation
problem?
I don't buy that.
So it depends on whether you think that
human brains are the kind of resource
that figures out how to do more with
less.
And that is what I think.
I mean,
there's been a huge argument for years
between the economists and the
biologists.
You know,
the biologists often the pessimistic and
they basically adopt a Malthusian
perspective.
And that is that we'll continue to breed
until we exhaust the planet and doing
our,
all of our resources.
And the economists always counter that
by saying,
hey,
don't be forgetting that we can
constantly figure out how to do more
with less than that.
We're pretty damn smart and I'm afraid
I'm on the side of the economists,
but even more to the point,
you know,
the projections right now indicate that
we'll probably peak somewhere around
nine or 10 billion something sometimes
by the middle of the 21st century and
then our population will start to
decline pretty precipitously.
And I think there's every reason to
assume,
especially at our current rate of
technological progress progression and
our increasing willingness to take
broader responsibility for the,
for the large scale health of the planet
that will be able to manage that without
too much problem.
We can certainly grow enough food to do
it.
If we put a little bit of effort into
that,
um,
we're going to squeeze out a lot of
other animals on the way,
I'm afraid,
especially some of the big predators
and,
and mammals that are of approximately
our size.
And that's,
you know,
there's,
there's a price to be paid for that.
I think there's more tigers now in
Texas,
just in case you're wondering the reason
the wild and the rest of the world.
And so,
but,
you know,
tigers tend to eat children and so it's
kind of rough having them around.
But in any case,
I'm not worried that we're going to
overpopulate the planet and,
and,
and destroy everything.
And I think that that's thinking that
basically hasn't advanced since the
1960s because,
um,
we are making tremendous progress in,
in pulling people out of the lower
echelons of poverty.
And there's a lot of terrible resource
misused at the lower echelons of the
poverty distribution.
So for example,
when people have to cook with wood,
um,
you know,
that that produces a tremendous amount
of deforestation,
for example,
and that kind of thing.
And,
um,
I think we'll get her act together if
we're fortunate peak around 9 billion.
The,
that we'll,
we'll be worrying about deep population
by the time some of the young,
younger people are old.
Um,
and besides you have kids cause that's
part of life.
So,
and it's,
it's the,
the two things aren't related in some
sense as far as I'm concerned.
So the trick is to have kids that are
more good than harm.
You know what I mean?
Because maybe because
people aren't only consumers,
there are also producers.
It's kind of appalling that we regard
ourselves as consumers.
So you know,
if you're going to have kids,
have good kids,
make them smart,
make them tough,
help them be tough,
you don't really make them,
help them be smart health and be
responsible and then,
you know,
maybe they'll do good and,
and that'll be good for the world and
people and like I'm pro people man.
And so I'm not worried about that.
So,
so,
you know,
I heard a university professor once who
I also thought was completely
reprehensible,
who was like lecturing to a group of 18
year old kids about how he and his wife
had only decided to have one child
because you know,
they didn't want to overpopulate the
world.
And I thought that if he'd only managed
to reproduce one genetic copy of him,
that was probably for the best.
But then he told the whole room full of
18 year olds that they should really
think seriously about whether they have
kids and if they have any,
they should just have one.
And I thought,
you son of a bitch,
you know,
you're such a,
you're so dedicated to,
to the destruction of humanity and so
rife with hatred for the human race that
you dare to stand in front of kids who
are just beginning their lives and say,
well you're such a,
you're a member of such a reprehensible
species that the last thing you should
do is multiply.
It's like,
no,
sorry,
I don't see any wisdom in that at all.
And I don't think the world does have an
overpopulation problem.
And I don't think that there's any
evidence that it does now.
That doesn't mean that we're managing
everything that we should manage
property,
like we're really wreaking havoc on the
oceans,
but Boyan Slat who's definitely worth
looking up,
boy on,
I think it's b o y a n and s l a t Dutch
kid has figured out he thinks how to get
rid of half the plastic in the oceans in
the next five years so you can go
support him.
That'd be a hell of a thing to do.
He's a real genius and there's lots of
ways that the burden that we're placing
on the our planetary resources is going
to be lifted and the trick is to get out
there and do something about it.
You know,
like Elon Musk is a good example.
It's like,
okay,
well maybe we're burning too many fossil
fields and maybe not because I think the
dangers of carbon dioxide are actually
somewhat overstated and I think there's
some decent evidence for that too.
But it's hard to sort it out because so
much of the climate change argument is
predicated on an underlying philosophy
such that if you're anticapitalist,
you believe that we're going to burn up
the planet.
And that's just not helpful because I
can't tell if your science is right or
if you're just anti-western an
anticapitalist.
So,
and like I spent three years working on
a UN committee,
uh,
that the Secretary Generals High Level
Panel on economic sustainability,
I think it was called and it produced a
report in 2013 and I spent about three
years reading everything I could get my
hands on,
on economic development and
environmental sustainability and the,
the state of the planet is far less
dismal than the doomsayers would have
you believe.
I do think that the one thing that we're
doing is like,
we're fishing out the oceans like
idiotically.
It's really,
really awful.
And trolling is a,
is a very damaging process.
And,
and I think that like if we left the
damn oceans alone for about 15 years,
they'd recover.
Not The great thought.
The huge fish like tuna because they
take a long time to develop.
But oceans would come back really
quickly and you know,
but I think we'll get smart enough to do
that sort of thing over the next 50
years because you know,
human beings aren't stupid and we've
actually only been worried about the
planet,
let's say since about 1960 it was only a
hundred years ago that it was more or
less self evident that the,
the natural world was inexhaustible in
comparison to the puny efforts of
humanity.
And you know,
we only figured out that there was
enough of us to cause trouble by about
1960 for Christ's sake.
How long do you expect us to,
how long do you expect it it to take us
to figure out how to take care of a
whole planet?
You know,
we're doing a pretty good job for people
who only stumbled onto the idea that
there might be a problem,
something like 60 years ago.
So I think we'll get it right,
especially if more and more people start
to act responsibly and truthfully and
all of that which,
and,
and start working for the betterment of
things instead of trying to,
you know,
undermine and hurt and,
and,
you know,
engage in identity politics and all that
sort of reprehensible,
reprehensible activity.
Okay.
Let's see.
What are your thoughts on using
psychedelics to help people overcome
traumatic experiences?
Um,
hey,
be careful because psychedelics can
cause traumatic experiences.
Like those things are no joke,
man.
Um,
I don't think we know enough about them
yet to make useful generalizations about
their hypothetical,
um,
clinical utility.
There's some decent studies indicating
with psilocybin for example,
that it might have utility in the
treatment of depression.
It looks like it's a really effective
smoking cessation medication,
which is really cool.
Um,
so,
but I think what happened was that when
the psychedelics burst onto the scene in
the 1960s,
they terrified us so much that like we
all recoil at their very existence and
then decided not to exactly.
Try to figure out what they were.
And I can understand that man,
because those things are seriously
weird.
Like they're there in comprehensively
strange.
I don't think we understand them at all.
I don't think we understand them any
more than we understand consciousness.
I think that they may have great
therapeutic utility,
but you know,
there are viciously powerful medications
and weapons and so you use them at your
own peril.
Something to that.
Carl Jung said,
I really liked because he talked about
psychedelic use a little bit,
although he was pretty old by the time
the psychedelics burst on the scene.
You know,
he said beware of unearned wisdom.
And I really liked that because even if
the psychedelics can open the gates of
perception and flood you momentarily
with,
you know,
with information of genuine cosmic
significance,
that doesn't mean that you're the sort
of character,
you're not the sort of vessel that can
tolerate being filled with that kind of
divine fluid.
You know,
it might just break and crack you.
So I would say,
you know,
approach those things with trepidation.
You should have the same attitude
towards psychedelics that the ancient
Israelites had towards the Ark of the
covenant,
which was that,
you know,
God was in there.
But if you touched it accidentally,
you would die nuts.
That's pretty good.
That's a pretty good general attitude.
Have with regards to any serious
encounter with psychedelics,
those things require respect.
They're not toys,
they're not games.
They're not fun.
What?
We don't understand what they are,
but you know,
they're,
they're worth treating with tremendous
respect.
Oh,
if we have betrayed or let people down
in the past,
how does one move on without guilt
turning pathological?
Oh,
well that's,
that's actually fairly straightforward.
The first thing I would say is you could
try using the past authoring program in
the cell for three,
uh,
sequence because it's actually designed
to help people do that.
But here's the issue,
man.
It's like you did something wrong and
it's hurting you.
Fair enough.
That hurts people.
And what you have to do is you have to
figure out,
okay,
what it was that you did wrong.
You have to figure out how it was that
you got there.
You have to figure out how to change
your life so that you won't go there
anymore.
You have to make amends for what you've
done,
not necessarily precisely to the people
that you did it too,
because maybe you can't.
But you need to start to live your life
in a way that makes amends for what
you've done.
And then you have to let it go because
people make mistakes and torturing
yourself to death because you did
something reprehensible and stupid isn't
as useful as using the experience to
transform yourself into someone moral
and useful.
So
now,
you know,
that's,
that's easier said than done obviously.
And I'm not,
I'm not in the least taking it lightly.
I know that,
you know,
you can do things in your life that are
very bad and that are very hard to get
over,
but
okay,
but adding your own misery to the misery
of the world when you could be out there
doing good is probably not the best way
to atone for your,
for your past sins.
So,
um,
you know,
and,
and people make mistakes.
The trick is once you've made it to
admit that you've made it to learn why
you made it to transform yourself so you
don't make it any more.
And then to go out there and start
acting like a proper person.
And it's one of the reasons I'm also
kind of attracted to,
to,
to some of the more fundamental elements
of the Christian doctrine because there
is a doctrine of universal forgiveness
that's embedded in that system.
But in the idea there basically is that
when people are fallible in a,
in a profound way,
but if they atone,
they can be redeemed.
And if they're penitent,
I mean that's where the word
penitentiary comes from,
comes from,
by the way,
if they're penitent,
if they go over their conscience,
if they confess to what they've done to
themselves,
to God in society,
let's say,
and they attempt to strike out on a
better path.
And that's all genuine.
It's like the idea as well.
Um,
if you don't allow people who've made
mistakes to move on,
then you just have to dispense with
everyone because everyone's made
mistakes.
Now,
having said that,
I know there's difference between
categories of mistakes,
but you know,
forgiveness after repentance is a good
moral axiom.
As a female,
I never had a great inclination start a
family after watching your material.
I'm struggling with how much of that
drive is my own brainwashing is my own
versus brainwashing versus third wave
feminists.
How do I parse that out?
That's a good question.
How would you parse that out?
Well,
I would,
I would start two things.
I would start by watching your dreams
and your fantasies because they can tell
you things that you first of all might
not want to know,
but also that you,
that you don't know.
But I would also say try making a case
for both sides.
You know,
like a really intelligent case.
So imagine that.
So you're trying to figure this out.
So the first thing you do is formulate
an argument where the proposition is
that you've been brainwashed by third
wave feminist and make the strongest
possible argument you can in support of
that.
And then put that aside and then do the
reverse and make the strongest argument
you possibly can.
In favor of the idea that you're,
that this is your own idea and that for
whatever reason,
you're not inclined to start a family.
You can even do the third thing,
which is to do another argument writing
about why you should have a family and
really like that's thinking,
right?
You got three arguments there.
You want to make each one of them is
strong as you possibly can,
like really sweat over it.
And then what having made the arguments,
allow yourself to contemplate them for
as much time as you need and it'll start
to become clear to you.
So that's what I would recommend.
So I follow your daughter's food blog
where she has recently talked about her
pregnancy.
What are your thoughts on becoming a
grandfather?
Well,
lucky me man.
I love kids and so,
and I get along really well with my
kids,
so that's so great.
I just can't believe it.
And they live near near me in Toronto
and uh,
now there'd be another candidate and,
and that'll be great for my wife because
loves babies and my daughter will like
that too.
And you know,
as I said already about babies,
you know,
they're not exactly,
I don't regard myself as a baby expert,
but once the kid is like nine months old
and older than that,
and especially between like two and 11
and teenagers too,
cause I like teenagers.
Um,
it's like hooray,
I love kids.
And so it's wonderful.
And I lived long enough to become a,
be a grandfather and you know,
I'm not,
I'm not three gorgeous dead yet or
anything like that.
And so hooray.
It's great and hopefully it will happen
some more.
So.
Okay.
Um,
if dominance hierarchies select for
heroes and breed them,
why then is Christ a celibate man?
Isn't celibacy and excuse for cowardice.
Oh,
that's a good one.
Yeah.
Well,
the first thing that's kind of odd about
Christ is an archetypal figure.
And this is something you commented on
his,
he died pretty young.
He was only 32,
you know,
so,
and young actually attributed the
obsession in our culture with youth to
the fact that our divine finger never
became mature.
Although you know,
we have the divine finger of God the
father,
which I suppose would fill out the
archetype to some degree.
Um,
why is Christ a celibate man?
Well,
I guess maybe you would say,
yeah,
if you're in a situation where you can
sacrifice yourself for the redemption of
all of mankind,
maybe adding the responsibility of an
individual family to that is just a bit
too much.
I mean,
I know that's a bit of a Glib answer in
some sense,
but there's something about it that's
the case.
You know,
I mentioned earlier that now and then
people have a calling of some sort that
supersedes other callings that they
could follow.
And I would say in the archetypal
representation of Christ that that's
something that could definitely be that
case could be made.
Um,
I,
I don't think that's a sufficient answer
though.
And I hope that when I get to the point
in the biblical series that I plan to
run until I get through the whole Bible,
if I can manage it and that upon to take
a couple of years.
That's the sort of question I'll be able
to address more fully.
Okay.
So let's go back to the live question
here.
Oh,
Zoltan Zoltar ftw I'm a BA in political
science concentration,
political theory.
I haven't had any job offers in anything
other than retail or all commission
sales in over a year.
What should I be applying for?
Well,
what I would say is take the best job
you can find.
That could be retail.
And I know retail jobs can be pretty
miserable,
but they may be better than no job at
all.
If you have a job,
you're in a better position to find your
next job.
People would rather hire someone
employed that someone who isn't employed
and,
and then you're also employed and you
have some structure in your life.
And then I would also say don't
underestimate the possibility of moving
up in a retail job.
You know,
you,
you can,
if you're smart and hardworking and
you're with a company that's smart
enough to bloody well recognize someone
like that,
the probability for advancement in that
kind of corporate structure can be
really great.
And so I would say if you're going to
take a retail job,
take the damn thing seriously and don't
feel like it's beneath you because every
okay
circumstance that you find yourself in
as a human being is rich enough so that
there's much that you can bring to it.
In terms of,
of of useful commitment,
you know,
like in a retail job,
well you have the opportunity to learn
how to interact with customers.
You have the opportunity to learn how to
sell you.
These are big bloody skills if you can
get them right,
you know,
you have the opportunity to learn how to
be grateful that you're not starving to
death in a ditch.
You know?
And,
and it's not such a bad thing to start
at the bottom because then you learn
what the bottom is like can you learn
how to move forward?
So I would say take the best job you can
find and then continue to look for other
jobs,
but,
but do the job right,
do it properly.
And one of the things,
and I've had lots of,
um,
what would you say,
I don't like to call them low end jobs,
but they're,
they're,
they're working class jobs.
I've had lots of working class jobs in
my life,
like dozens of them really.
And they're not trivial.
You can learn a lot in a,
in a working class job and you know,
you can learn how to get along with your
employee,
with your peers.
You can learn how to get along with your
supervisors and be useful to them and
maybe be drawn to the retention if they
have any sense.
I mean,
if you have a retail job and it's,
they're treating you like a miserable
slave and if you're doing a good job and
you get no credit for it,
it's like get the hell out of there as
fast as he can.
But you want to find somewhere where if
you work hard and you're a reasonable
person,
that people are going to notice that and
open up doors of opportunity for you.
That's kind of the definition of a
healthy company.
And you can find that virtually
anywhere.
So don't be thinking that the retail
jobs are necessarily,
you're not going to be there forever,
you know?
And with a Ba you often have to start at
the bottom,
but that doesn't mean that that's where
you're going to end up.
So,
so don't,
don't feel too dismal about that it,
it's a start man.
And that's something,
and you could go into the retail job and
you could think,
okay,
like if I was really smart about this
and I was really regarding this as an
opportunity,
how can I knock this out of the park?
And that's a good thing to think about.
And it beats the hell out of,
you know,
sitting there,
and I'm not saying that you're
necessarily doing this,
but feeling sorry for yourself because
you know,
you've got a degree in the world isn't
an opening itself up to you.
It's like maybe it is,
maybe the retail job is opening itself
up to you.
So,
and then you work hard on developing
your career.
You've got a toehold in there.
And I know that's,
maybe you might regard that as naively
optimistic,
but that beats naively pessimistic.
And I,
but I also do believe,
and I've seen this happen many times,
is that you can,
okay
if,
if your attitude is if you have yourself
put together properly,
let's say sorted out properly,
you can make a hell of a positive impact
on the world in a relatively low level
position.
You know,
cause you could make the person who
walks into the store,
your retail operation,
you could make the next 10 minutes of
their life a hell of a lot more pleasant
than they might be if you were miserable
and resentful and you know,
maybe they'll come back again and maybe
the store will thrive.
That's especially true if you start
working for a smaller business man.
You can have a big effect on a small
business.
So don't be thinking that there's no
opportunity there.
You know,
it might be your inability to construe
that as opportunity.
That's the,
it's what's interfering with it.
Believe me,
I know that,
um,
especially chain retail jobs and
especially if you have a dismal
authoritarian manager,
that those jobs can just be hell.
But so I wouldn't recommend staying in a
job that's hell and where there's no
further movement,
but don't necessarily think that you not
being an offer offered an opportunity if
you can take any job at all.
You got to start somewhere man.
And,
and,
and the bottom,
like I said,
the bottom started bad place to start
because he learned down there and
someone who gets really good at business
across time,
let's say,
knows whatever enterprise they're in
from the bottom up.
And that's what makes them competent.
So,
and they don't say,
oh,
well the things that the Baltimore too,
they're not good enough for me because
the things at the bottom are really what
the business rests on.
And you need to know how those things
work.
And then you also have some sympathy for
the people who are maybe stuck in those
positions forever,
which you wouldn't be,
you know,
you won't be.
So,
okay.
Okay.
Um,
let's see here.
What time is it?
Nine oh two and we started at seven 30.
Let's go to nine 30.
That's probably good enough.
So that's about 20 more minutes.
Um,
Fab fab.
You ballinger advice for a breakup after
four years?
It's been 1.5 years and I still believe
she's the one,
well,
I would say she's at one and look,
some people really pair bond hard,
you know,
to put it in crass biological terms.
But if she's moved on and that's
serious,
you know,
then I would say start,
start going out with other people,
you know,
really and,
and start
just because she's the one doesn't
necessarily mean she's the only one,
you know,
and
one and a half years that's long enough
so that you should be starting to
okay.
To Act as if you're getting over it.
And if you're having real trouble with
that,
then I think you should probably find
someone to talk to and talk that out and
figure out what your strategy is.
But I would say get the hell back into
life,
man.
Now,
if you know,
maybe there's part of you that still
thinks that there's some possibility of
rekindling the relationship and fry.
No,
maybe that's possible.
It seems unlikely because I don't think
that you would.
Okay.
I don't think that you would be asking
that question if you thought that was a
possibility.
But I would say I'm going go find some
other people,
man,
and admit to the possibility that there
might be someone else out there that
will work with you and get on with your
life because you're going to be old a
lot faster than you think.
And you don't want to be stuck in
stacy's any longer than necessary
because then you've lost the woman and
you've lost your time and losing the
woman is bad enough.
But losing the woman and your time,
that's really not good at all.
So,
uh,
let's see.
How do you get over hiding something
because of the fear that people will
think of you differently or treat you
worse,
especially for family members and others
close to you.
Yeah,
Quintin good width.
You know,
Quentin,
I don't know what to say about that
because it depends on what your,
it depends on what you're hiding,
you know?
So
I'd like to answer that question,
but it's not detailed enough.
The devil with questions like that,
man,
the devil is often really seriously in
the details.
And uh,
I just,
if you think that you're hiding it
because of cowardice,
that's one thing.
But like you might have a real problem,
you know,
when you're hiding something that really
would cause serious repercussions in
your social circumstances and in your
family,
in which case,
you know,
it's a hell of a tough thing to deal
with.
And I would say you need to find someone
that you can talk to that you trust
that's wise and maybe that'll be a
professional.
But,
um,
or I would say the same thing that I
mentioned earlier to,
to someone who had a similar question
about strategy is like,
write down a strategy.
And then the other thing you could do
too that's useful is imagine the worst.
Okay.
Imagine you reveal whatever this is and
the worst happens.
Lay out the worst.
So you understand it.
You know,
it'd be be realistic about it and then
figure out how you would handle it.
You know,
like,
you could imagine,
well everyone now hates me so much I
have to move to a new town.
Well maybe you could do that,
you know,
and once you know that you could do
that,
then maybe you wouldn't be so afraid
about it.
So it's often the case that people are
terrified about the terrible things that
might happen is cause they won't really
think through what the terrible things
are and what they would do.
And so think it through.
Think the catastrophe through and think
about how you would cope with it if it
happened.
And that should encourage you to some
degree.
So Benjamin would question what's wrong
with maslow's?
Uh,
what's wrong with maslow's hierarchy in
my,
I was just writing about that yesterday
day before and in my new book by the
way,
um,
maslow presumes that you have to meet
your material needs before you can meet
your spiritual needs.
And that's wrong.
That's just not right.
It's not wise.
I would say.
Um,
the read Viktor Frankl's man's search
for meaning,
that's a good antidote to that.
And also again,
I would say read Social Knutson's Gulag
archipelago,
especially volume two because Social
Knutsen has done a tremendous job of
dispelling the idea that material
security and comfort is a prerequisite
to higher order psychological and
spiritual being.
So,
so I think what's wrong with maslow's
hierarchy,
the idea of maslow's hierarchy is that
it's far too materialistic and its
fundamental orientation.
Now having said that,
you know,
that doesn't mean that there's nothing
useful in maslow's thinking.
I think that his discussions of self
actualized persons are actually very
interesting and the idea that,
you know,
there are higher levels of human,
human psychological and spiritual
development and he was thinking about
more secularly I think is also extremely
useful.
But I think the idea of the manner in
which you progress through the hierarchy
is wrong.
I also think it's a socialist idea in
some sense because the,
and a utopian idea,
because the idea is the way that you
bring about the perfect human societies
by making sure that everyone's material
wellbeing is,
is,
um,
is established.
And look,
I know people need to eat and I know
that they need security and all of that.
I understand that.
But assuming that that's a prerequisite
for spiritual development is an error,
and assuming that it's a necessary
prerequisite is even a more,
uh,
egregious error,
I would say.
So can you further explain your
disapproval of Ayn Rand?
I don't really disapprove of Ayn rand.
I liked reading her novels,
you know,
and I think it's funny because I was
given Ayn rand's novels by a woman named
Rachel Notley,
who is the mother,
was the mother of,
because unfortunately she's deceased of
the current socialist premier of
Alberta.
Rachel Notley who was a friend of mine
when I was kid and it was her mother who
has an avowed socialist of the,
of the pro working class classical type
who gave me Ayn rand as well as George
Orwell and Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn and
eldest Huxley,
a whole raft of really high quality
literature,
literary books.
And uh,
she wanted to be,
she wanted to expose me to that
philosophy.
And like I found Ayn rand's books I
really liked reading of,
they're really romantic.
Um,
they're,
they're interesting adventure stories,
I would say.
And you know,
Ayn rand had a point.
I mean,
she had a hell.
Her family had a hell of a time with the
communists in the Soviet Union.
Like she had reasons for doing what she
was doing.
But the problem with Ayn rand as a
literary figure is that all here heroes
are the same people and they're
completely heroic.
And the whole,
her villains are the same people,
the same person,
just in different bodies.
And they're all almost completely
reprehensible.
And so,
you know,
one of the hallmarks of high quality
literature is that the battle between
good and evil isn't just fought out
between the good guys and the bad guys.
Like at a cultural level.
That would be an identity politics
issues say and that it's not the good
guy as an individual who's like the next
Messiah in,
in,
in Ayn rand,
that would be the capitalist Messiah.
And then the evil,
reprehensible,
satanic figure.
And you know,
all of the good traits are embodied in
one and all of the bad traits in the
other,
in in really sophisticated literature.
I would say that even the villains have
good qualities.
Like villains are way more interesting
when they're also interestingly good and
you know,
risk the cove in crime and punishment is
a good example of that.
And all of dusty huskies villains for
that matter because they have deeply
admirable qualities.
Like Ivan for example,
who's not exactly a villain but,
but he,
he certainly atheistic,
which,
which put them at Owens with Dostoyevsky
in the brothers.
Karamazov I mean,
Ivan has everything going for him.
He's good looking.
He's dashing.
He's young,
he's brave.
He's,
uh,
he's,
he's got military training.
Like he's,
he's,
uh,
he's clearheaded,
he's a hell of a villain.
He's a great villain man and Ayn rand.
It's just like,
it's just too formulaic in my
estimation.
And so it starts to verge on the
ideological,
and she was primarily motivated by
making a political point rather than by
writing literature in my estimation.
So that's all.
I mean,
and having said that,
I would also say I got great pleasure in
reading Ayn rand's books,
so I'm not,
I don't precisely disapprove of her.
She isn't,
she just isn't a top rate philosopher
and she's also not a top rate literary
figure.
And those are the reasons she's little
bit to propaganda stick and her
characters are too unidimensional.
So yeah,
that's why.
Okay.
Let's see here.
Uh,
fresh sweet says Jordan is a mental
midget.
Well,
I'm tall,
so I at least I'm also,
I've got some elements of me that aren't
entirely midget likes.
So,
um,
uh,
let's see.
So what else do I have to say about
that?
Um,
while it's conceivable that fresh sweet
is a mental giant by comparison,
but I doubt if he or she would have used
that in salt if that happened to be the
case.
So let's see,
someone said please,
can I say their name?
And the answer to that is no,
because I've
mmm,
lost your question.
So I read your question,
but I'm not going to say your name so
well that's,
that's ironic I suppose.
Oh,
sharp girl,
Sikhs.
Are there evil persons with no redeeming
qualities?
No,
that would be just too simple,
man.
Yep.
It'd be nice if that was the case,
you know,
you know what I mean?
Not exactly nice,
but know that it just isn't how life
works,
man.
It's,
it's as social knits and said,
you know,
even in the best person,
there's still some uprooted,
uprooted corner of evil.
And even in the person who's gone as far
down the rabbit hole as you can possibly
go,
there's some still shining element of,
of,
of the divine quality of humanity that
could be communicated with.
So at least that's how it looks to me.
So,
okay.
How do you make time to read for
leisure?
I,
right now I don't,
in fact,
I don't make enough time to read period
and,
but I hope to rectify that.
Sue.
Mostly I'm,
I'm editing the things that I'm writing
and mostly I'm writing.
So,
um,
but when I do read most of the,
I've read before I go to bed,
I go to bed and I read for half an hour,
an hour or something like that.
So
okay,
I'm 23 wheelchair bound.
I can't afford college and don't have
the services to get me through it.
And I'm glad I found you online.
My favorite subject is psychology.
I'm very intrigued by it.
Great.
That's native to wise.
Hey,
so good man.
Watch the lectures and then go take a
look at my reading list at Jordan B.
Peterson,
dark tom and get those books you can
get.
Most of them used online for next to
nothing.
And even the ones you have to buy,
man,
it's worth it.
Or get them from the library or
something like that.
So,
and,
and you know,
you can educate yourself to a large
degree.
You got a f I'm going to expand that
reading list,
two to maybe a hundred bucks or
something like that because Jesus,
especially what's really funny about
books too is the better the book,
the cheaper it is.
It's so funny because you can buy
penguin classics,
for example,
literature classics for like 1 cent plus
shipping.
What a deal,
you know,
so,
and some of them you can just get for
free now because the copyrights have
expired and you can download them on
your kindle and they don't cost you a
sense.
So what do I do for fun?
Hmm,
what do I do for fun?
I build things in the backyard.
I like doing that.
Um,
I play ping pong with my son,
except I taught him how to play ping
pong and now he's way better than me,
just stumps me in and that any laughs a
lot about that.
So that's very annoying.
Um,
I spend time with my wife,
although not enough,
especially in the last seven months
because I've been completely overwhelmed
by all of this.
Um,
what else do I do for fun?
Snack on social justice warriors.
That's kind of entertaining.
MMM.
Spend time with my family.
That's probably the biggest thing.
I talk with my friends.
Um,
you know,
standard sorts of things like that.
Um,
I find most of what I do in my life
extraordinarily engaging and
entertaining.
So,
um,
except when I'm overwhelmed by it and
that's been,
that's happened to be partly because of
the mood issues I talked about,
but also partly because like the last
seven or eight months,
it's really been
both surreal and overwhelming.
I'm usually so engaged in what I'm doing
that,
um,
I,
I wouldn't say I'm not looking for
funding exactly.
It's that I have a bunch of it already.
Kyle Mitchel says,
what should I do if my girlfriend isn't
satisfying me sexually?
How do I get her to progress with me?
Oh,
well,
that's a place that you can usually use.
Really use both discourse and reward.
It's like,
okay,
well,
what do you want?
That's the first question.
And you know,
could you make your wants known and are
there ways that you can express the fact
that you're happy about that that would
be compatible with the person's desires?
You know,
it's a lot of,
it's a lot of that is often lack of
communication.
But you know,
you could also do what skinner did when
he was training rats,
which is watch your partner,
you know,
during sexual encounters and otherwise,
and when they do something that you
really like and really want them to keep
doing,
like let them know,
you know,
that's intelligent use of reward.
But a lot of it is just discussion.
You know,
it's like first of all,
figure out what you want and discuss
with the person what you want and find
out what,
why they're objecting and you know,
do some negotiation.
And if you can't talk,
here's a good rule of thumb.
I think for especially for young people
who are engaging in new relationships is
it don't do anything sexually with
anyone that you couldn't talk to them
about before you did it.
I think that's a funny one.
So,
and I think it's true too.
Okay.
Jordan,
what are your thoughts on George Orwell?
Brilliant.
George Orwell man,
more power to him.
He was,
he was really something like he,
he was a major influence on me and you
know,
he was beating,
he was climbing the warning bell about
communism,
you know,
a good 30 years before the corrupt
French intellectuals woke up,
had admitted that they'd been
worshiping,
uh,
you know,
a murderous tyrant for the last almost
century.
I really go George Orwell man and he's
such a clear writer.
Great scs.
Like a real,
a real example for anyone who wants to
learn to write.
That's Orwell like hemingway,
you know,
um,
although I think that or Orwell was a
greater figure than hemingway.
All things considered.
Hemingway could really write it tight
sentence man.
And he could,
he could say a lot with,
with very few words and that's really
something worth worth taking a look at
too.
Okay.
Tjf Advice.
Advice for aspiring academics,
specifically philosophy graduate
students that read every God damn thing
you can get your hands on.
Matt,
read all the great philosophers and,
and,
and make notes and write about them as
well.
Till you understand them until you have
them under your belt.
And so,
and do that at the same time while
you're going through getting your
degree.
You know,
because a lot of the education that you
get in university at graduate level
isn't going to be very good.
The courses are generally not very good
in my experience.
But man,
read,
there's great people to read.
So start at the beginning,
you know,
go back to socrates and,
and,
and read everything you can get your
hands on and,
and do the work necessary so that you
understand the philosophers and you can
start like,
I found real useful way to start
introducing yourself to philosophers is
pickup and this is good for everyone
else who's out there to pick up like,
um,
a plato for dummies or,
or,
or Nicha for dummies or you know,
one of those illustrated introductions.
Christ,
it's a good start.
You start slow and,
and start building up your expertise and
move towards the,
the actual,
you know,
the actual difficult writings
themselves.
So
how do you motivate yourself to do
something that you do not enjoy but you
deem important?
Like studying for exams?
Good question.
Um,
ask yourself what would motivate you?
You know,
first of all,
don't be studying eight hours a day
cause that isn't going to work and
you're not going to do it anyways.
You know,
when you start studying five minutes a
day,
seriously,
would you,
could you bring it up to 10 minutes a
day?
What would you have to do for yourself
to get yourself to sit down for half an
hour a day and,
and study intently?
Like maybe you'd have to,
I dunno what you'd have to do,
like have a beer at six o'clock at night
or something.
Or maybe you'd have to go for a walk in
the park or go out for coffee.
It's like,
imagine that you're sitting down with a
stupid undisciplined child who,
and you're trying to get that child to
do something useful.
And you say,
okay,
look,
I want you to do x.
It's necessary,
but you can pick how much of it you're
going to do.
And I'll give you what you want if you
do it well,
ask yourself that and see what happens.
So don't try to tyrannized yourself,
you know,
try to negotiate with yourself and use
some reward and see how that works and
start slow.
You know,
maybe,
maybe you're not very disciplined and
the best you can do is half an hour of
studying a day.
Well,
start with half an hour.
Increase that five minutes a week.
You know,
if you do that,
that's a lot.
If you,
if you do that for a year,
then you'll,
by the end of the year,
you'll be studying four hours a day.
So you can,
that's,
that's just with five,
that's just with five minutes a week,
right?
Because that's 250 minutes in a year.
So start ridiculously pathetically,
um,
study for five minutes a day for a week
and then move it to 10.
You'll be able to do that and don't
cheat.
You know,
because one of the things people do is
they make a deal with themselves like
that.
I'm all,
I'm going to study for 10 minutes a day
each day.
And then they,
they get into it,
they think,
wow,
this is going really good.
So they study for two hours and then
they broke the contract with themselves
and they don't trust themselves anymore.
And then they don't study for a whole
year or well,
maybe not for a month.
So,
but set your contract,
ask yourself,
you know,
what could I do to move myself forward
to my goal that I would do and then how
can I improve that incrementally?
So that's the right way of going about
that.
So,
okay.
What do you think about the line that's
often fed to young people to do what you
love and follow your dreams?
Well,
you know,
there's something to be said for doing
what grips you,
but you know,
you have to Lr that with discipline.
That's the thing.
And you have to ally with
responsibility.
And so,
and,
and I would also say that that advice
say,
which,
which I think has been most popularly
associated with Joseph Campbell,
was actually to some degree something
that was at least initiated by young.
But one of the things you said was more
like follow what grips and compels you.
And it will take you into the underworld
where you will encounter your shadow
when the dragon and,
and when,
when you put it that way,
it's a lot more realistic.
It,
it's just to a naive and,
and,
and too good to be true to be a good
doctrine.
Although I think there's some,
there's an element of truth in it.
You do want to follow your dreams but
not if your dream changes every 30
seconds.
You know,
like with the future authoring program,
one of the things we get people to do is
to detail out a vision for the future.
If you could have the future that you
dreamed of having,
what would,
what would that dream be?
That's really useful.
But then the next part of the exercise
is,
okay,
how are you going to do the hard
discipline,
multiyear work necessarily necessary to
bring that dream into reality and how
are you going to make that realistic and
implementable on a day to day,
um,
on a day to day on a day to day level.
So you got to bring your dream down to
Earth,
man and,
and,
and act it out.
And you have to disciplined to do that.
And so that's,
that's the part that's missing there is
um,
do what you love and discipline
yourself.
That's a good combination.
What are your thoughts on sleep
paralysis?
That happens to me all the time.
So it exists.
I mean
I often have,
it happened to me this weekend for
example.
It's quite,
it's quite
comical.
So if I go to sleep on my back,
sometimes I will dream that I'm trying
to wake up,
but I can't.
And so I am trying to wake up but I'm
asleep and I'm still paralyzed because
you get paralyzed when you're in rem
sleep so you don't run around and act
out your dreams and smash your nose into
a wall like cats do if you take that
part of their brain out.
And so I often dreamed that I'm kind of
semi comatose and I know I can't wake up
and I'm like grabbing out my daughters
sleeve too and saying throw cold water
on me or shake me or something or push
me out of bed because I can't wake up.
And then she'll ignore me and then I'll
try and get my wife to do it in my dream
and it like,
it seems like it lasts an hour.
And then finally I'll shake myself awake
and I'm often end up when I wake up like
that,
I'm often annoyed because I'd be telling
my family members as far as I'm
concerned for like half an hour
desperately to wake me up and they'd
been ignoring me.
Of course it's probably only taken five
minutes and they don't have any idea
what's going on.
But it often,
I think it has something to do with
Sarah synergic malfunction and it's that
might be related to this mood disorder
that I described,
but,
but it's also much more likely to occur
if you lay on your back and sleep on
your back.
And also if you do it in the afternoon,
so,
um,
and people can have quite horrifying
experiences with sleep paralysis.
There's a good book called the,
uh,
the terror that comes in the night about
sleep paralysis and nightmares and it's
quite an interesting investigation into
that phenomena.
So,
um,
oh,
your essay writing guidance has proven
invaluable.
Well,
thank you that that refers to that
thing,
that writing exercise that you can find
on my psychiatry psychology for 30
website.
I'll try to find a better place to put
it.
Um,
maybe I'll tweet about it again.
I'm glad it's invaluable.
It's taken a long time to figure out how
to write it.
Do you have any guidance round taking
notes from books and lectures?
Yeah,
yeah,
no problem.
Like don't be taking notes during the
lecture.
Exactly.
Because then you're not listening to the
lecture.
It's like listen to the lecture and then
take notes afterwards.
Now that doesn't work for every
discipline,
but,
but it certainly works for disciplines
like students in my lectures,
I always tell them,
don't take notes during the lecture,
listen to the damn lecture.
You can take notes afterwards because
what that does is force you to practice
remembering.
And then with regards to books,
it's like read,
don't highlight,
don't underline like that.
I think that that's just rubbish.
I think it's pseudo read a couple of
paragraphs or maybe an essay,
something like that.
Depending on the density of the book.
Close the book,
think about it.
Write down what you're thinking,
write down what you remember.
But,
but,
but in the context of what you're
thinking about because that instantiates
it into your memory and give and puts it
at hand.
Like people ask me for example,
how it is that I can remember all the
things that I talk about
extemporaneously when I'm lecturing.
And the reason for that is because I've
thought them through,
you know,
I read them and I think,
oh,
okay,
well that's an interesting idea.
How does it relate to all these other
ideas that I know?
Like,
what is it,
significance for this idea and what's
its significance for this idea and do I
believe it and how my,
I criticize it.
So it's Kinda like I'm,
I'm attaching little memory hooks to it
in,
in five different ways and then I've got
it.
It's part of me.
And that seems to be part of recall
rather than,
so rather than recognition and recall is
the spontaneous act of remembering
something complex.
And when you recall something,
you're actually practicing remembering
it and that's what you need to do if you
want that to be part of you.
So I would say separate out the function
of reading and note taking.
So read,
think,
write or read.
Write.
Think though,
because the last two things are quite
similar but don't like read the book and
then read a sentence and then write down
that sentence.
That's not helpful.
You could read the sentence,
close the book and then reformulate the
sentence so that now it's your sentence
man.
Then you'll remember it.
Then you'll understand it.
That works really well.
What a postmodernist have right?
There is an infinite number of ways to
perceive the world.
Yeah.
That's what they had.
Right.
And that's bloody major discovery.
It was the same discovery that blew the
slats out of artificial intelligence in
its early instantiation in the 1960s.
So the idea that the world is so complex
that there is in principle in infinite
number of ways to perceive it is
correct,
but the idea that there is no order of
rank difference between those modes of
perception,
that's just,
that's where the postmodernist went
completely off the rails.
So they just,
they,
they got the problem right.
But they didn't take their thinking
about it nearly far enough.
So,
um,
okay.
Let's say you mentioned switching to a
Paleo Diet some time ago and from the
way your physical appearance seems to
improve,
I would say it's working quite well.
Could we have more details into your
diet?
Yeah,
you could.
Um,
for a year and a half I basically
haven't eaten any carbohydrates,
so I wouldn't recommend it though cause
it's really not it,
it's hard and it also makes you
unpopular.
I can't really go to restaurants.
It's very difficult for me to go to
other people's places to eat.
Um,
it makes traveling a real pain.
but I'll tell you if you want to lose
weight,
man,
and that is really why I did this by the
way,
but if you want to lose weight,
if you cut carbohydrates out of your
diet and go on a paleo diet,
heavy protein and Greens and that sort
of thing and you can eat a lot of that
so you don't have to be hungry.
My experience has been,
and you know,
it's not the same with everyone,
but I also know other people who've
tried this out.
My brother in law who's actually quite a
great genius has he's 60 now and he's in
better shape than he was when he was in
45 45.
He's a bloody monster.
That guy really tough,
really physically put together,
super smart.
And he's followed a Paleo Diet for about
15 years and like he doesn't have an
ounce of fat on them.
So if you want to lose weight,
drop the carbs and you'll lose weight so
fast you won't believe it and you don't
have to be hungry.
So I don't want to go into it more depth
because it's Jesus Christ.
I've spent so much time talking about my
bloody diet over the last year that it
just bored me to death.
That's so funny because it's so funny
because just before last September when
I made those first videos,
I was sitting around for my family and
we'd been talking about Diet God nonstop
because partly because of my daughter's
health problems and elsa mine,
it's like every day discussion about
diet.
And I was just paralyzing me and I
thought,
God,
I hope,
I wish that we could find something else
to talk about.
It's like,
well that's your happened.
So what is your advice for people that
aren't very social and have a hard time
making friends?
Get the hell out there and practice,
man,
I had a client,
very introverted,
very introverted person,
very badly served by her parents.
Uh,
not very well socialized,
extremely socially anxious,
awkward in her social interactions as
well.
So not skilled.
Um,
she d and also alone,
she didn't have an intimate relationship
or really any family.
So quite,
quite isolated person and terrified of
social interactions.
Like she couldn't even go out and have a
coffee with me as her therapists as a
practice exercise when we first met and
man,
she's made progress like you wouldn't
believe like terror,
unbelievable progress.
Um,
you know,
doing public,
doing public appearances on stage,
even um,
gold.
Go take a,
go to toastmasters,
do some public speaking,
uh,
join meetup.com.
Um,
ask people questions.
You know,
that's a really good thing.
If you're not very social and,
and you'll get self conscious,
you start thinking about yourself and
how stupid you are,
that's a really bad idea.
You should be paying attention to the
other person.
So if you get nervous,
it isn't that you have to stop being
nervous because that isn't going to
work.
What you have to do is start paying more
attention to the other person.
You have to force your attention
outward.
And you know,
you can ask people questions,
listen to them.
And when they say something interesting
or they say something you don't
understand,
ask them a question.
And people love that man because they
know you're listening to them and people
love being listened to.
So if you're learn to listen better and
learn to ask questions and there's no
stupid questions if you're paying
attention,
right?
And so you don't have to worry about
that.
If you don't know something,
if you don't know something and you ask
an honest question and someone treats
you badly because of it,
then you should just go away from that
person because they don't have a clue.
So get out there,
um,
forget about trying to not be nervous
because you're going to be nervous.
But when you're nervous,
pay more attention to other people.
Listen to them carefully.
Watch them,
because then your natural social
abilities will kick in and ask them
questions.
And you know,
your assuming it'll take you three or
four years to get decently good at it
and that you'll really have to work at
it.
But it's worth it,
man.
So,
so just go out there and do it and,
and you'll,
you'll figure it out.
You'll figure it out.
So all right guys and girls and,
and assorted others.
It's nine 30 and uh,
well that was fun.
I hope it was fun for you.
And I would like to say in closing two
things.
Number one,
thank you very much for the,
not just for the monetary support,
you know,
although I hope to put that to good use.
I,
that is definitely my plan.
But also the public support I've
received has been extremely practically
and psychologically useful to me.
You know,
because there was a lot of stress in the
last year and,
and my job was definitely in danger at
the University of Toronto.
It's certainly my autonomy as a
professor was,
and the fact that I received all this
public support was extraordinarily
useful for me to buttress my sense that
I was pursuing the right course of
action even though I wasn't doing it
perfectly.
And it was,
it was very,
it helped me protect myself to a great
degree practically.
I mean,
part of the reason that university had
the,
let's call it the opportunity to back
off in,
in the face of all the objections that
were raised by the social justice
warrior types is because there was a
counter protest from the general public.
And so thank you very much for that.
It's much appreciated.
And with regards to the money man,
like my,
my plan is to while a to remain very
grateful for it and not to take it for
granted,
but the man,
I'm going to try to do some viciously
good things with that.
So,
and uh,
I freed up my time for the next year and
I want to capitalize on this.
I want to capitalize on this opportunity
and I want to bring classical humanities
education to millions of people and
Jesus,
that's such a good deal.
So,
um,
so thanks very much.
It's very much appreciated.
So we'll talk to you again soon and I
hope you enjoyed the q and a and
tonight.
Oh,
oh.
And I'd like to thank my son Julian
because he's helped me set up all this
technology and that's been really good
of him.
And,
and,
and it worked.
So parade for that.
Bye.
Now I have to figure it out.
I shut this off.
First blank shot
then done.
Bye.